WE HAVE OUR FOR OUR FIRST AUTHOR
HERE SENATOR WIENER.
ARE YOU READY TO PRESENT
.
SENATOR.
GOOD MORNING.
AND YOU HAVE SB -- SIXTY NINE SO
GO HEAD WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
SIR.
THANK YOU -- MISTER VICE CHAIR --
BEFORE I WOULD BE AND I WILL --
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEES TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS -- SPAMMER PRITCHETT
THE COMMITTEE ON THE CREATES
TOUGH WORKING WITH US ON THIS
BILL -- SB SIXTY NINE WHICH IS
THE OCEAN RESILIENCY OCT -- TO
TWENTY NINETEEN WILL HELP
RESTORE HABITATS AND ENCOURAGE
PRACTICES THAT INCREASE
SEQUESTRATION OF A SO CALLED
BLUE CARBON.
SEC -- I SUCH AS THE BENEFICIAL
REUSE THE MARINE SETTLEMENTS TO
BUILD OPERATOR WETLANDS.
EXCUSE ME WE ALSO NEED TO
PROTECT OUR ECOLOGICALLY
CRITICAL SPECIES INCLUDING THOSE.
ON WHICH COASTAL ECONOMIES RELY --
THE BILL WILL PROTECT WHALES BY
CODIFYING AN EXISTING VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM AIMED AT PREVENTING SHIP
STRIKES.
SB SIXTY NINE ALSO TAKES A
NUMBER OF LONG OVERDUE STOPS. TO
BEGIN REBUILDING OUR SALMON
FISHERIES INCLUDING PLACING NEW
PROTECTIONS ON THE FORESTS
STREAMS OF WHERE THEY SPAWN.
AND I'VE BEEN -- ALTHOUGH --
WANT TO SAY I KNOW THERE WAS A
LETTER FROM THE TIMBER INDUSTRY --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
TIMBER INDUSTRY FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THIS LEGISLATION --
THERE IS SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS
AND THE SENATE THAT ADDRESSED
THE LION'S SHARE OF THE TIMBER
INDUSTRY'S OBJECTIONS.
WHICH HAS MADE FURTHER
AMENDMENTS LAST WEEK TO ADDRESS
MORE OBJECTIONS.
AND SO I JUST WANNA MAKE CLEAR
THAT THE TIMBER INDUSTRIES
OBJECTIONS TO THE BILL -- THOUGH
IT IS DRAMATICALLY SMALLER THAN
WHAT IT WAS WE DID RECEIVE THEIR
VERY TECHNICAL LADDER LATE LAST
WEEK WE ARE REVIEWING IT -- AND
I'M CONFIDENT THEY'LL BE SOME
ASPECTS OF IT THAT WILL BE ABLE.
TO ACCEPT BUT WE HAVE NOT FULLY
EVALUATED AT YEAH AND WILL
CONTINUE. TO WORK WITH THE
TIMBER INDUSTRY AS WE HAVE FROM
THE BEGINNING OF THE BILL.
THIS MEASURE -- AND ITS VARIOUS
PROVISIONS WILL HELP ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA HAS THE STRATEGY AND
THE ABILITY TO MITIGATE THE
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE ON OUR
OCEANS. TO SEQUESTER GREATER
AMOUNTS OF CARBON UNTIL THE
COASTAL COMMUNITIES TO CONTINUE
THEIR WAY OF LIFE INTO THE
FUTURE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE --
WITH ME -- TODAY ARE CAITLYN
KALU OF THE CALIFORNIA COAST
OPPENHEIM OF THE PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATIONS THANK YOU OKAY.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
A GOOD MORNING THANK YOU CAITLYN
COLUSA WITH THE CALIFORNIA COAST
KEEPER ALLIANCE -- I AM WHICH
REPRESENTS LOCAL WATER KEEPERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BIG FROM
THE ORGAN BORDERED ON THE SAN
DIEGO AS WELL AS INLAND INTO
SIERRA.
I'M SPEAKING TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL SIXTY
NINE A CRITICAL ACTION ORIENTED
BILL TO INCREASE THE RESILIENCE
OF CALIFORNIA'S MARINE AND
COASTAL ENVIRONMENTS CLIMATE
CHANGE.
GLOBAL CARBON EMISSIONS ARE
DRIVING CHANGES TO OCEAN
CHEMISTRY.
AND A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH IS
NEEDED TO INCREASE THE VIABILITY
AND SURVIVAL OF MARINE AQUATIC
SPECIES TO THE CHANGES THAT ARE
DRIVEN BY CLIMATE CHANGE.
SB SIXTY NINE OUTLINES CRITICAL
STATEWIDE.
ACTIONS CALIFORNIACAN TAKE NOW
TO INCREASE THE RESILIENCE OF
INDIVIDUAL AQUATIC SPECIES AND
ECOSYSTEMS CLIMATE CHANGE BY
REMOVING CURRENT THREATS AND
BOLSTERING THE ECOSYSTEMS OF
THESE KEYSTONE SPECIES. THREE
CRITICAL COMPONENTS I'M GONNA
HIGHLIGHT TO YOU TODAY ARE THE
BENEFICIAL REUSE OF JUDGE THAT
MEANT FOR BUT WHEN RESTORATION
ACROSS ALONG THE COAST.
OVER THE PAST CENTURY MOST OF
CALIFORNIA'S WETLANDS HAVE BEEN
FILLED OR CONVERTED TO OTHER
USES LEAVING THE STATE WITH 10%
OF ITS HISTORIC WETLANDS.
SB SIX NINE WILL HELP CALIFORNIA
CHIEF IT'S NO NET LOSS POLICY.
I'M BY AND ALSO SUPPORT WILL
THROUGH SUPPORTING BENEFICIAL
REUSE OF JUDGE SETTLEMENT FOR
RIGHT WING RESTORATION WHICH
PROVIDES CRITICAL HABITAT FOR
NUMBER OF COASTAL SPECIES AS
WELL AS MIGRATORY BIRDS.
AS OLD PERSON PROTECTS COASTAL
COMMUNITIES FROM SEAT RISING SEA
LEVELS INCREASE STORM SURGE.
SB SIXTY NINE ALSO ENCOURAGES
THE VOLUNTARY VESSEL SPEED
REDUCTION PROGRAM.
I'M WHICH ACTUALLY BUILDS FROM A
PILOT PROGRAM AT THAT WE'VE SEEN
IN THE SANTA BARBARA CHANNEL IN
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA THAT
HOUSES GOT SUCCESSFULLY.
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF FATAL WILL
STRIKES AS WELL AS DECREASE THAT
SMOG PRODUCING.
EMISSIONS LONGER BECAUSE BY OVER
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY TONS I SB
SIXTY NINE WILL EXPAND.
THE SUCCESS OF THIS PROGRAM --
AS WELL AS FINALLY.
SB SIXTY NINE WILL IMPROVE
INSTREAM FLOW FOR CRITICAL
SPEECH -- SALMON SPECIES AND
OTHER FISH -- SALMON AND OTHER
FISH SPECIES ARE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT IN THAT THE
CONNECT FRESH WATER IN MARINE
ECOSYSTEMS.
SB SIXTY NINE WILL REVIVE
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS TO
DETERMINE AND MAINTAIN THE
MINIMUM INSTREAM FLOW TO PROTECT
THESE CRITICAL FISH SPECIES.
I GATHER THESE PROGRAMS AND
SPECIFIC ACTIONS WILL PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS TO COASTAL
ECOSYSTEMS AND THE RESILIENCE OF
MARINE SPECIES BY MITIGATING
THREATS.
POSED TO THE SPECIES BECAUSE OF
THESE EXPLICIT ACTIONS AND THAT
THESE ARE NOT SIMPLY PLANS.
ARE WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTY NINE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S.
NO OPPENHEIM WITH THE PACIFIC
COAST FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATIONS OF COURSE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AS ORGANIZATION IS A CO SPONSOR
AND I WANT TO TAKE OUR TIME
TODAY DID SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT
WHERE THIS BILL WAS AND WHERE
IT'S COME.
TO OF COURSE WE KNOW THAT SALMON
FISHERIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN DEEPLY
DEPRESSED IN THE LAST SEVERAL
DECADES FISHERMEN ONCE NUMBER
OVER.
FOUR THOUSAND IN THE COMMERCIAL
SECTOR WE NOW HAVE FEWER THAN
FOUR HUNDRED FISHMAN ACTIVE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE NEED
TO PRIORITIZE RECOVERY AND THIS
BILL DOES SO IN A NUMBER OF
SURGICAL AND EFFECTIVE WAYS.
WE'LL TALK FIRST ABOUT THE WORK
THAT THIS BILL WOULD DO TO
ENHANCE OUR STATES HATCHERY
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
COULD UNDERTAKE THERE ARE THREE
SECTIONS RELEVANT TO THAT TREE
PROGRAM [inaudible] ONE WOULD.
L. AUGMENT THE EXISTING OFFSITE
RELEASE PROGRAM WITH A NEW A NET
PEN RELEASE ON THE COAST.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM THIS IS A LIFE LINE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL.
SALMON ECONOMY THE SECOND
SECTION OF THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THE STATE TO IN PERIODS
OF DROUGHT.
MOVE FISH OFF SITE TO RELEASE
THEM IN RIVER IN STRATEGIC WAYS
PIONEERED BY FOLKS LIKE THE
MANAGERS OF THE EAST BAY MUD CO
MANAGE MCCAULEY RIVER HATCHERY
WHICH IS AN EXTERNALLY
EXTRAORDINARILY EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM.
THE THIRD IT WOULD BE A HOLISTIC
PROGRAM -- TO INSTITUTE REFORMS
IN THE WHOLE CALIFORNIA HATCHERY
PROGRAM THINGS LIKE -- PARISHES
BASED TAGGING ANOTHER.
REFORMS THAT WOULD GET THE
PROGRAM MODERNIZED IN LINE WITH
THE REST OF THE WEST COAST
STATES AND WE WORKED ON THAT
PARTICULAR SECTION WITH.
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT IN
THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS TO
REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION AND TO
GET TO A POINT WHERE WE FEEL
THAT WE CAN WORK IN TANDEM WITH
THE WATER USE OUR COMMUNITY TO
ENHANCE THIS PROGRAM.
ON THE TIMBER HARVEST SECTIONS.
THE THE BILL HAS BEEN REFINED
SIGNIFICANTLY AS SENATOR WIENER
SAID MOVING FROM.
A PRETTY BROAD AND AND ARGUABLY --
ON ORTHODOX APPROACH -- TO
REGULATORY REFORM TO
PRIORITIZING SOME KEY AND
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT OF REMEDIAL
EFFORTS FOR A TARGETED LIST OF
WATER COURSES ONLY THOSE WATER
BODIES THAT ARE IMPAIRED FOR THE
POLLUTANT SENTIMENT.
THAT ARE KNOWN TO PRODUCE SALMON.
EXCLUSIVELY AND TARGETING NO
OTHER AREAS THOSE AREAS ARE
KNOWN TO BE IN NEED OF OF THIS
SIGNIFICANT REMEDIATION AND WE
KNOW THAT REMEDIATION FROM
TIMBER HARVEST PRACTICES USING
THE APPROACHES THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING WITH COMMITTEE STAFF
WILL.
IMPROVE THE SITUATION ON THE
STREAMS WE ARE WORKING ON
PUTTING TOGETHER A RESPONSE TO
THE TECHNICAL SUGGESTIONS THAT
THE TIMBER INDUSTRY HAS MADE.
AND BECAUSE THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE IS THE
COMMITTEE OF JURISDICTION OVER
THOSE EFFORTS THAT'S WHERE THOSE
CHANGES WILL BE MADE AND WE CAN
ASSURE YOU NOW THAT THOSE THERE
WILL BE TECHNICAL CHANGES MADE
IN ONE WEEK'S TIME OF THAT
COMMITTEE -- AND WITH THAT I'D
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT AND I
FEEL LIKE WE WILL HAVE.
A DEEP CONVERSATION HERE IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION.
I THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING TO RESPECT WHICH ON
BEHALF OF HEAL THE BAY IN
SUPPORT.
SIR SOLVE ANY ON BEHALF OF
INLAND EMPIRE WATERKEEPER AND
HUMBOLDT BAY KEEPER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
NATALIE NEXT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA TROUT IN SUPPORT.
BRENNAN DAWSON OVER HAVE A
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
I'M BETWEEN -- KATHY COLUMBIA OF
THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS IN
THE METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HERE
REPRESENTING A HANDFUL OF UP
WATER INTEREST WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE.
OF PROPONENTS AS WELL AS
COMMITTEE STAFF ALL OUR CONCERNS
HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED THANK YOU.
PHIL THISALISHA ON BEHALF OF
THE PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION AND WE ARE
LOOKING SPECIFICALLY AT THE
VESSEL SPEED REDUCTION SECTION
OF THE PROGRAM WE WOULD LIKE
SOME ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY
REGARDING.
SHIP SPEED SO WE WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION WITH
THE AUTHOR IN THE BILL'S
SPONSORS THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION
.
YOUR SINGLE QUICKLY WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL -- A LITTLE
HISTORY THE BILL WAS AMENDED --
LAST TUESDAY WE WORKED AS A
COALITION TO GET A RESPONSE TO
THOSE AMENDMENTS -- WITHIN FORTY
EIGHT HOURS AND HAVE THAT OUT
FOR EVERYONE'S -- PURVIEW -- WE
ARE STILL OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
WITH THIS BILL WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THE
BILL WAS THE SECTION THAT WE
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT BEFORE HAS
BEEN REMOVED IT HAS BEEN
REPLACED BY. TWO NEW ADDITIONAL
SECTIONS THAT WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS OVER
CONSENT AND BEYOND JUST
TECHNICAL CONCERNS -- SO WE
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE AMENDMENTS ARE COMMITTED
TO BEING TAKEN BEFORE THIS BILL
MOVES OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE --
OUR MOST SIGNIFICANT -- CONCERN
INVOLVES SECTION NINE WHICH
REQUIRES THAT -- TIMBER
HARVESTING IS PROHIBITED ON
GROUNDS THAT SHOWS EVIDENCE OF
EXTREME EROSION POTENTIAL UNLESS
THE TEACH P. HAS BEEN APPROVED.
BY A CERTIFIED ENGINEERING
GEOLOGIST FIRST OF ALL THERE IS
NO CURRENT DEFINITION FOR
EXTREME EROSION CONTROL BUT
RATHER EXTREME.
EROSION HAZARD RATING AND
SECONDLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION WHICH INCLUDES THE
CALIFORNIA GEOLOGICAL SURVEY
THEY ARE ALREADY A PART OF THE
REVIEW TEAM FOR ALL TEACH PEAS
WE WANT TO REQUEST THAT THE
LANGUAGE STATE THE TIMBER
HARVESTING ACTIVITY SHALL NOT BE
UNDERTAKEN.
UNDER TIMBER HARVESTING PLAN
SUBJECT TO SUBDIVISION NAY ON
GROUND SHOWS EVIDENCE OF EXTREME
EROSION HAZARD RATING.
UNLESS THE TIMBER HARVESTING
PLAN HAS BEEN REVIEWED BY THE
CALIFORNIA GEOLOGICAL SURVEY --
WE HAVE ASKED THE SPONSORS OF
FOR THE IMPOTENCE OF THIS BILL
AND WHY THEY THINK THAT IS
NECESSARY TO REGULATE -- OUR
TIMBER HARVESTING PLANS WHICH
ARE CURRENTLY REGULATED BY THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY CAL FIRE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
INCLUDING THE GEOLOGICAL SURVEY.
AND THE REGIONAL WATER QUALITY
CONTROL BOARDS -- AND IN
RESPONSE TO THAT THEY GAVE US
STUDIES WOULD WENT BACK AS FAR
AS NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
OBVIOUSLY TIMBER HARVESTING
PRACTICES ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
DIFFERENT.
THAN THOSE THAT WERE DONE IN --
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WE'VE HAD
SIGNIFICANT UPGRADES IN THE
RULES THROUGH THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY AND WE THINK THAT'S
WHAT'S MOST APPROPRIATE TODAY.
MORNING MR MEMBERS BRING WHITE
HERE FOR THE CALIFORNIA LICENSE
FORCES ASSOCIATION AND FORCE
MAMMALS OF CALIFORNIA WE TOO
MUST RESPECTFULLY CONSIDER
OPPOSE THE BILL A WE DON'T
DISAGREE WITH SOME OF THE
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL THE
OVERALL CONTENT OF THE BILL WITH
RESPECT TO OCEAN RESILIENCY.
THAT'S A NOBLE A BECAUSE WE WE
ARE NOT OPPOSING THOSE
PROVISIONS IT IS THE SPECIFIC
PROVISIONS ON THE FORTY PIECES
OF THE BILL THAT ARE STILL
CAUSING CONCERN.
AND I'LL I'LL JUST WALK YOU
THROUGH SOME OF THOSE THOSE
ISSUES A GRAND ITS MOST OF THESE
CONCERNS ARE PROBABLY THE
PURVIEW OF THE SUMMING UP TO
RESOURCE COMMITTEE BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR ENOUGH FOR US TO
RAISE THIS NOW.
BECAUSE WE THINK THESE ARE VERY
SUBSTANTIAL PROVISIONS NOT JUST
TECHNICAL -- PROVISIONS AS AS
WILL POINT OUT TO LICENSE FOR
STILL SHE ATION WE ARE ACTUALLY
THE STATE'S RENTS ARE
PROFESSIONAL FORESTERS AND WE
WORK FOR PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
ENTITIES.
IN APPROVING TIMBER HARVEST
PLANS.
AT THIS POINT OUT TO TEACH PEACE
ARE SINCE THE SICK LIKE
DOCUMENTS AND LOOK AT EVERYTHING
INCLUDING SETTLEMENT IN THE ROAD
AND RELATED ISSUES WHICH STILL.
THIS WHICH THIS BILL CHANGES
UNDER THE PRESUMPTION THAT THE
CURRENT PROCESSES IN WORKING
ORDER.
SO CALLED REDDITOR GAPS.
THIS COULD BE FURTHER FROM THE
TRUTH THE T. H. P. PROCESS
REQUIRES REGISTER PROFESSIONAL
FORESTERS TO WORK WITH ALL THE
STATUS AGENCIES THAT WERE LISTED
INCLUDING. FOR FORESTRY PART OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE.
WE DON'T WATER QUALITY CONTROL
BOARD AND APARTMENT CONSERVATION.
THESE TEACH PEACE LAST BETWEEN
FIVE AND SEVEN YEARS COST ABOUT
400-004-0000 TO SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS EACH.
SOLD THEIR NOT INSIGNIFICANT AND
THEY MUST BE REVIEWED AND
RENEWED EVERY FIVE SEVEN YEARS.
THERE'S ANOTHER PROCESS CAUGHT
THE NON TIMBER.
MANAGEMENT PLAN THESE ARE FOR
NON INDUSTRIAL CAM IMAGINE PLANS
EITHER FOR SMALL LANDOWNERS
WHICH ALSO REPRESENT.
THESE ARE MORE -- OF TIMBER
HARVEST PLANS ARE DONE FOR FOLKS
THERE ARE ACTUALLY IN THE
BUSINESS OF HARVESTING TREES FOR
FOR PROFIT OR PRODUCTS.
THEY DON'T TO MANAGE THE LANDS
THEN USUALLY ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED ACRES OR LESS.
AND ASSEMBLY THESE LANDOWNERS
ARE ARE LAND RICH BUT THERE CASH
PORCELAIN HAVE RESOURCES.
TO SPEND THOUSAND SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON T. H. P. SO THEY GO
THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
DIFFERENCE THOUGH IS THAT THE IN
TEAM P. AS A ONE TIME APPROVAL
PROCESS IT LASTS FOR THE
ENTIRETY OF THE OF THE PROJECT.
AND LESS LANDER SUCH ACTION
HARPER STREETS THEN THEY GO
THROUGH WHAT'S CALLED THE T. H.
P. R. OR I NOTICED OPERATE.
THE PROCESS DOESN'T END JUST
WITH THE T. H. P. OR THE NTP THE
BORDER FORESTRY HAS DONE
NUMEROUS THINGS OF THE LAST TEN
YEARS INCLUDING THE THE SUMMIT
PROTECTION RULES.
THE ROAD RULES WHICH GET AT SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT I THINK THE
SPONSORS TRYING ADDRESS WITH
RESPECT THE SALMON PROTECTION.
AND THERE'S ALSO BEEN ISSUES
THAT ARE UNRELATED FORESTRY AS
WE KNOW WITH WITH DROUGHT.
THE MORE WATER WE HAVE THE
SYSTEM THE BETTER IS FISH
SPECIES AND THE DROUGHT WHILE
STILL A CONCERN.
AND WE MUST DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THAT IT HAS IMPROVED THIS
SPECIES IN THE OCEAN.
WHICH IS ACTUALLY A POINT OUT IN
VARIOUS RECENT RECENT ARTICLES.
I PUT ALL THIS OUT BECAUSE THE
PROCESS IN THE NARRATIVE THAT IS
UNTIL SORRY SIR LOOK FOR ME --
JUST REALLY QUICKLY ESTABLISHED
QUORUM WHILE WE HAVE IT -- SO A
MAN CLICK COULD YOU CALL THE
ROLL.
EDUARDO GARCIA GALLAGHER HERE
GALLAGHER PRESENT BIGELOW.
BIGELOW PRESENT CHOI HERE CHOI
PRESENT [inaudible]
TO FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA PRESENT GLORIA.
KALRA.
KALRA PRESENT LEVINE.
MATHIS.
MATHIS PRESENT BLANCA RUBIO.
LOCKER REVEAL PRESENT SALAS
WOULD.
WOULD PRESENT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU KNOW PLEASE PROCEED OF
BUT PROJECT OR NOT THE PROMISED
HER AND I'LL BE BRIEF I'LL WRAP
THIS UP REAL QUICK SO OTHER
FOLKS CAN CONSIGNMENT BUT UPON
ALL THIS OUT SINCE BUT STATE
THAT THE CURRENT PROCESS.
IS WORKING IF THERE ARE EFFORTS
AND NEEDED TO IMPROVE THE
PROCESS.
THOSE ARE PROBABLY MORE MORE
LIKELY ADMINISTRATOR PROCESS WE
DO AGREE WITH THE THE A
PROVISION THE BILL WE KIND OF
STUDY. TO SEE IF THERE'S MORE
RECENT DATA OTHER THAN TWENTY TO
THIRTY YEAR OLD DATA THAT.
MR PICKY REFERENCE.
THE BORDER FOR FREE I WILL KNOW
IS CURRENTLY EMBARKING ON A
STUDY SO THIS THE PROVISIONS IN
THIS BILL SEEM TO BE CONSISTENT
WITH THE STUDY THAT'S GONNA BE
CURRENTLY DOWN BY THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY.
AND FINALLY I'LL JUST MENTION
SPECIFIC IN SECTION NINE OF THE
BILL THIS IS THE MOST TROUBLING
PIECE IN THE BILL.
BECAUSE THEY SAID THE T. H. P.
CANNOT BE APPROVED.
ON GROUND THAT SHOWS EVIDENCE OF
EXTREME EROSION CONTROL UNLESS
APPROVED BY A GEOLOGIST
CERTIFIED GEOLOGIST.
THAT FLIPS THE PHP A PROPER WILL
PROCESS ON MY MEMBERS WERE RICH
OPPRESSION FORSTER'S BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE LEGAL ENTITIES THAT
APPROVED EACH PIECE WITH CAO CAO
FIRE.
SO WE CANNOT ACCEPT THAT
PROVISION THE BILL SO THE AUTHOR
AGREED TO TAKE.
THAT PROVISION OUT AND MAKE IT
MORE FOR A REVIEW PROCESS MORE
THAN APPROVAL PROCESS.
BY GEOLOGIST WHICH ARE COUNTY
PART THE REVIEW TEAM ANYWAY.
WE WILL BE MOST LIKELY OKAY WITH
THIS BILL MOST OF THE BILL IS IS
GOING TO BETTER DIRECTION EXCEPT
FOR THAT PARTICULAR SECTION.
SO WITH THOSE -- ISSUES --
MISTER WE WE ASK FOR OPPOSE LESS
AMENDED LESS THAT BUSINESS
ADDRESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THIS NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
NUMBER.
ROBERT SIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION I'D LIKETO
LINE MY COMMENTS WITHOUT A BOTH
THE CALIFORNIA FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
PRIVATE FOREST LANDOWNERS AND
THE REGISTER PROFESSIONAL
FORESTERS WE TOO ARE OPPOSING
LESS AMENDED ON THIS AND AND AND
FRANKLY.
OUR CONCERN STEMS FROM THE IDEA
THAT THIS BILL IS TRYING TO PICK.
WHICH INTO T. AND WHICH
OPERATION WHICH COMMERCIAL
OPERATION.
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DEGRADATION OF THE SAME SPECIES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND IN MY TEN YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
HAVING BEEN PART OF PROBABLY TWO
DOZEN DIFFERENT HEARINGS BOTH
INFORMATIONAL SUCH.
FOR ON THIS VERY TOPIC.
WE KNOW THAT IN FACT IT'S A
COMBINATION OF MULTIPLE MULTIPLE --
MULTIPLE ISSUES DEPREDATION
BEING.
ONE CLIMATE CHANGE BEING ANOTHER.
AS WELL AS HIS NAME NAME AND
POSITION THANK YOU SIR ROBERT
SIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
SALARY NEVER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
OKAY A BRING THEM.
YES.
AND THE COLLEGES I'VE I'VE WAS
WANTING TO GIVE EVERYBODY A
LITTLE BIT OF LIBERTY AND ELLIS
IS A BIG BILL A LOT OF DIFFERENT
ISSUES.
YEAH SO -- ALL DIG IN YOU KNOW
MAYBE FIRST HERE ON ON SOME OF
THESE ISSUES.
ONE SENATOR I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR WORKING -- PROACTIVELY WITH
OPPOSITION ON ON THIS ISSUE AND
IT SOUNDS LIKE THERE HAS BEEN
PROGRESS MADE -- AND I KNOW
THAT'S NOT TELL YOU THAT'S BEEN
YOUR REPUTATION IS THAT YOU DO
WORK THROUGH THESE DIFFERENT
ISSUES AND SO APPRECIATE THAT --
I WANT TO START WITH SOME
AGREEMENT THAT HAVE IS IS IN AND
AND MAYBE SOMETHING TO THINK
ABOUT AS YOU'RE MOVING FORWARD
IS.
ON THIS RE USE OF SETTLEMENT --
AB I WAS TALKING WITH THIS FROM
MY COLLEAGUE -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN LAST YEAR ABOUT WE HAVE A
HUGE AMOUNT OF SEDIMENT BUILDUP
IN THE FEATHER RIVER. FOR
INSTANCE -- OVER THE YEARS BUT
WE HAD A BIG IMPACT AS A RESULT
OF THE ORVILLE DISASTER.
AND I AND I THOUGHT THAT THERE
IS A REALLY BIG WIN WIN IF WE
CAN SOMEHOW GET OUT THAT
SEDIMENT BUILDUP.
THIS BEEN GOING ON IN OUR AND
AND SOME OF OUR RIVER SYSTEMS --
AND AND THEN RE USE THAT
SETTLEMENT FOR EXAMPLE IN
BUILDING YOU KNOW UP COASTLINES.
YOU KNOW BEACH IS OVERSEEN THAT
SIGNIFICANT EROSION -- THE OTHER
IS EITHER A QUICK BARGE TRIP
DOWN TO THE BAY OR YOU KNOW SOME
WAY OF DOING THAT.
WOULD IT WOULD ALSO BE A WIN FOR
SALMON BECAUSE ONE OF THE BIG
PROBLEMS WE HAVE IS THE
SEDIMENTATION -- YOU KNOW IS
COVERING UP SALMON SPAWNING BEDS
RIGHT -- AND SO.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'VE YOU
KNOW HAVE YOU HAD ANY
CONVERSATIONS ON THAT FRONT OF
REUSING I SEE THAT IS USING IT
FROM THE REDWOOD CITY -- BAY.
THERE BUT IF HAVE YOU CONSIDERED
CONNECTING THIS TO LIKE REDUCE
OF SENTIMENT THAT.
YOU SAID IT MEANT -- REMEDIATION
PROCESS IS -- PROJECTS IN RIVERS
IN THE NORTH STATE FOR EXAMPLE
AND USING THAT AS AS RECESS AT
IMITATION IS THAT SOMETHING YOU
GUYS HAVE TALKED ABOUT.
IF I'M IN THIS VENTURE --
BENEFICIAL REUSE IS A IS A
TREMENDOUSLY POPULAR PROGRAM
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR
PREVENTING COASTAL EROSION IT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE STATE WATER
BOARDS BEEN WORKING ON FOR SOME
TIME IN TERMS OF THE INLAND TO
COASTAL CONNECTIVITY FROM AREAS
AS FAR AWAY AS THE FEATHER.
UNDER FOR KTRE STICKS AND
UNFORTUNATELY AND KIND OF TOUGH
TO ACCESS FROM A REGULATORY
PERSPECTIVE IT'S IT'S A DAUNTING
CHALLENGE ONE THAT WE CERTAINLY
SUPPORT I MEAN.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
CONNECTIVITY BETWEEN RIGHT
PERRIN INTEREST REAL AREAS AND
COASTAL ECONOMIES THAT THOSE
CONNECTIONS ARE DEEP THEIR THEIR
COMPLEX AND WE NEED TO BE DOING
BETTER -- I WOULD SAY THAT IS
THE THE HISTORY OF THIS BILL HAS
BEEN.
FOCUS AND AND AND REFINEMENTS
RATHER THAN EXPANSION BUT I'D I
THINK THIS IS IDENTIFYING A KEY
ISSUE.
AND ONE THAT WOULD CERTAINLY
LOVE TO WORK WITH THE ANA BUT
AND THEN I HAD ASKED THE LOOK AT
THE LOWER FOR THERIVER CORRIDOR
MANAGEMENT.
PLAN THAT WAS DEVELOPED BY IDW
ARE -- SO THERE'S ALREADY A PLAN
ON THE BOOKS ABOUT DOING SAID IN
A MANAGEMENT IN THE LOWER
FEATHER RIVER AND SO.
MAYBE IT'S JUST A CONVERSATION
AS AS MS FORD LIKE TRYING TO
MAYBE SEE IF THERE'S A WAY TO
CONNECT. TO SOME OF THOSE PLANS
THAT ARE ALREADY IN PLACE HAPPY
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION -- ALSO --
YOU KNOW ON THE HATCHERIES I
MEAN I THINK THAT'S A HUGE ISSUE
WE NEED TO I THINK THERE'S MORE
WE CAN DO TO IMPROVE.
YOU KNOW BOTH -- YOU KNOW THE
THE SALMON POPULATION USING
HATCHERY.
USING THE HATCHERIES AND ALSO
BETTER.
YEAH -- I THINK THERE'S BEEN AND
THERE'S SOME MUCH NEEDED
IMPROVEMENT ON WHERE WE'RE
RELEASING.
JUVENILE SALMON AND WHEN WE'RE
DOING IT -- AND AND AND MANY
PEOPLE IN MY AREA BEEN VERY
CRITICAL -- YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY
THE THIS THE SPORTS FISHERMAN'S
ASSOCIATION OTHERS ABOUT THESE
WHEN THESE ARE BEING RELEASED
HIS LIKE.
AT A TIME WHEN PREDATORS ARE AT
AN ALL TIME HIGH -- ME OF FOR
EXAMPLE IS STRIPER -- AND SO WE
YEAH WE LOSE A SIGNIFICANT
POPULATION THERE JUST BASED ON
WHEN THESE THINGS ARE HAPPENING
SO IF WE CAN DO THINGS TO
IMPROVE THAT I THINK THAT'S VERY
KEY.
AS THIS MOVES FORWARD -- ON THE
ON THE FORESTRY SIDE AND I THINK
ALL THIS ALL THIS COMES TO THIS
COMMITTEE BECAUSE ULTIMATELY
WHAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON HERE IS
SALMON AND OUR WATER WAYS RIGHT --
AND HOW THEY ARE ALL CONNECTED.
RIGHT ALL COME YOU KNOW FROM THE
UPPER WATERSHED ALL THE WAY DOWN
INTO THE BAY IS -- YOU KNOW
THERE IS THAT CONNECTIVITY.
WHAT I THINK WHERE THE A LOT OF
THAT WHERE THE OPPOSITION IS
COMING FROM?
IS THAT THE SEDIMENTATION ISSUE
IS NOT THERE'S NO DATA THAT
SUGGESTS IS REALLY COMING FROM
FORESTRY PRACTICES ANYMORE.
WHEN WE WERE AT THE HEIGHT OF?
NO TIMBER HARVEST.
YOU KNOW THERE WAS STUDY SHOWING
THAT BUT OBVIOUSLY HAS BEEN A
LOT OF CHANGES.
AN WELL RESTRICTIONS LIMITATIONS
ON TIMBER HARVEST.
AND SO YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT
OTHER SOURCES FOR THAT
SEDIMENTATION TODAY -- YOU KNOW
ONE OF THEM BEING JUST YOU KNOW
LIKE WE SAID WE HAD THIS
DISASTER ON OROVILLE DAM WHERE
OR LIKE MILLIONS OF CUBIC YARDS
OF OF MATERIAL WERE DUMPED INTO
THE FEATHER RIVER.
RIGHT -- YOU KNOW THERE'S
DIFFERENT.
YOU KNOW THINGS LIKE THAT --
CONTRIBUTED TO AND THERE'S NO.
DATA HERE RECENTLY SUGGESTING
THIS COMING FROM TIMBER HARVEST
AND SO.
I THINK ONE OF THE THOUGHTS WAS
WHY NOT DO A NEW STUDY.
YOUR OF HER KIND OF FORCE --
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY TO DO A
NEW STUDY TO SEE IF THAT IS IN
FACT THE CASE AND OTHERWISE
THERE IS A TIMBER HARVEST PLAN.
PROSTHESES YOU KNOW PROCESS IS
ALREADY IN PLACE I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WAS BEING SAID A LOT ABOUT
POSITION.
THAT DOES CONSIDER ALL THESE
ASPECTS.
BEFORE TIMBER HARVEST PANT PLAN
IS APPROVED -- AND AND UNLESS
THERE'S LIKE A A REALLY STRONG
JUSTIFICATION FOR DOING SO.
YOU KNOW WHY SHOULD WE CHANGE
THAT MAYBE THE FIRST THING FIRST
AS A SAY HEY WHERE'S THE
SEDIMENTATION.
ISSUE COMING FROM RAY AND DO
THIS AND MAKE THIS MORE FOCUSED
ON THE STUDY OF THAT.
FIRST.
AND THEN TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
POLICY SHOULD BE.
ASSOCIATED THEIR WITH NOW I I I
SEE THAT YOU DID CHANGE THAT.
IN THE SAID.
NO THERE WILL BE A STUDY IN A
WILL BE UPDATED.
ACCORDINGLY -- I THINK THERE'S
MAYBE SOME QUIBBLING OVER THAT
LANGUAGE BUT I THINK THE BIGGER
ISSUE IS.
THE THE REQUIREMENT THAT YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A EROSION CONTROL
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN -- SEPARATE
AND APART FROM WHAT'S ALREADY
INCLUDED IN THE T. H. P. PROCESS.
RIGHT NOW AND MAYBE MAYBE COULD
ADDRESS I MEAN I I THINK.
WE'RE NOT HERE TO CLAIM THAT THE
TIMBER INDUSTRY IS LIKE THE SOLE
SOURCE OF OF SEGMENTATION OF
REMEMBER SAID THAT AND BUT I I
ALSO DON'T THINK IT'S THE CASE
THAT IT'S NOT A FACTOR -- AT ALL.
A AND SO AS YOU NOTED WE HAVE.
MADE SOME CHANGES IN THAT IN
THAT SECTION WE ALSO YOU KNOW WE
THERE WAS OF THE ISSUE ABOUT THE
REORDERING.
OF WHICH AGENCIES WE'RE GONNA BE
IN CONTROL WE TOOK THAT AL -- WE
TOOK THAT SECTION AL AND IN THE
LAST.
AMENDMENTS.
AND WE PUT OTHER MOMENTS IN
THERE ARE NO CONCERNS ABOUT THAT.
BUT I THINK I EVEN THOUGH WE
STILL HAVE OPPOSITION IS NOW
GONE FROM.
OPPOSED TO OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
THAT'S PROGRESS -- AND WE HAVE
YOU KNOW BEEN WILLING TO MAKE.
A HAVE DIALOGUE AND MAKE AMENDS
YOU KNOW THAT WE CAN AGREE.
TO AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT --
BUT YOU KNOW.
AND I WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
DIALOGUE AND THAT OPEN DOOR.
RIGHT NOW AND I RESPECT THAT BUT
IT A WHAT MY MY CONCERN IS THEY
SEEM TO BE THE ONLY INDUSTRY
THIS REALLY AFFECTED THOUGH
THAT'S WERE HAVING THESE
ADDITIONAL REGULATIONS ON TOP OF
WHAT THEY ALREADYHAVE TO DO AS
PART OF A TIMBER HARVEST PLAN.
LIKE FOR INSTANCE I DON'T SEE
ANYWHERE IN HERE.
NEW REGULATIONS ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
AND HOW THEY OPERATE.
ORVILLE.
WHEN I WAS A HUGE INCREASE TO
THE AMOUNT OF SEDIMENTATION THAT
WE SAW IN THE FEATHER RIVER FOR
EXAMPLE -- I DON'T SEE LIKE
ADDITIONAL REGULATION ON ON
THESE OTHER SOURCES RIGHT THAT
THEY'RE PART OF THE SOURCE OF
SEDIMENTATION THAT WERE SEEN.
IT JUST SEEMS THAT THEY'RE THE
ONLY ONE THAT HAS AN ADDITIONAL.
REGULAR WITHOUT REALLY HAVING
ANY NEW DATA. TO SUPPORT THAT I
THINK THAT'S MY CONCERN I THINK.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY SAYING HEY
THAT THEY SHOULD BE REVIEWED IN
THE SHOULD BE OVERSIGHT OF WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
IN TERMS OF THEIR TIMBER HARVEST --
I THINK THEY'RE JUST SAYING AND
AN EIGHT AND I THINK THEY WOULD
ARGUE THERE ALREADY IS A LOT OF
THAT GOES INTO THAT PLAN THAT
THEY HAVE TO CONSIDER -- BUT
BEFORE WE ADD A NEW REQUIREMENT
ON THEM.
YOU KNOW SHOULD WE HAVE A STUDY
THAT SHOWS THAT THERE'S ACTUALLY
THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE A SOURCE OF
INCREASED SEDIMENTATION OR THAT
THERE'S YOU KNOW A MORE RECENT
STUDY THAT SHOWS THAT.
IF I MAY THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION MISTER VICE CHAIR AT
THE THE FACT THAT.
NEARLY EVERY SINGLE MAJOR AND
SIGNIFICANT SALMONBERRY WATER
COURSE ON THE NORTH COAST IS
LISTED FOR STATEMENT POLLUTION
ON THE THREE A THREE D. LIST.
IS A TESTAMENT TO THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE LINGERING ONGOING
PROBLEMS WHETHER THERE'D.
CAUSED BY LEGACY PRACTICES.
OR BUY NEW OPERATIONS THAT
OCCURRED IN THE RECENT PAST THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT THESE
AREAS ARE IMPAIRED AND
REMEDIATION NEEDS TO OCCUR.
WITH RESPECT TO THE POINTS THAT
THE WITNESSES MADE ABOUT SECTION
NINE ABOUT THE EXTREME HAZARD
RATING AND APPROVAL BY
GEOLOGICAL.
SURVEY THOSE IN MY VIEW OUR
TECHNICAL AND WE'RE I'M
PERFECTLY WILLING TO SAY THAT
WERE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND THE OTHERS OFFICE TO ADDRESS
THOSE PARTICULAR CONCERNS BUT TO
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT EROSION
CONTROL PLANS OR ROAD IN CONTROL
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS.
EROSION CONTROL IS IN MY VIEW A
CRITICAL PREREQUISITE FOR
OPERATIONS THE REGION ONE BOARD
IS ALREADY MOVING.
TOWARD THE PROCESS FOR EROSION
CONTROL PLANS IN.
TIMBER OPERATIONS BEYOND THE
SCOPE OF WHAT'S ENVISIONED IN
THIS BILL.
SO THERE'S THERE'S ALREADY A
PROCESS MOVING FORWARD FOR THIS
APPROACH AND FRANKLY IN MY VIEW.
THESE THESE PLANS ARE A CRITICAL
PART OF RESTORING AND
REMEDIATING.
THESE IMPAIRED WATERSHEDS AGAIN
IT'S A SURGICAL APPROACH TO ONLY
THE AREAS WE KNOW WHICH SEMINAR
WHERE WE KNOW THEIR SENTIMENT
PROBLEMS.
AND THAT'S IT THE HUGE
CONSOLIDATION REFINEMENT FROM
PREVIOUS LANGUAGE WE'RE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE CONTINUE
THE DISCOURSE AS WE MOVE THE
PROCESS ALONG IN THERE JUST ONE
FINAL QUESTION ISN'T EROSION
CONTROL ALREADY CAN BE REQUIRED
UNDER A T. H. P..
RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT.
SO I MEAN DON'T THEY ALREADY
HAVE THAT TOOL IS WHAT I'M
SAYING SO WHY ADD ANOTHER.
WELL IT WOULD IT IF I MAY.
MISTER RUSSIA I BELIEVE THESE
EROSION CONTROL PLANS WOULD LOOK
VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT'S ALREADY
IN MANY T. H. PEAS BUT THERE ARE
MANY OTHERS THAT.
COULD IN OUR VIEW -- HAVE THAT
ADDITIONAL LEVEL OF PROTECTIONS
AGAIN FOR THIS.
VERY SMALL SET OF PHP IS THAT
ARE AROUND -- ADJACENT TO THESE
IMPAIRED SENATE BEARING
WATERCOURSES.
THANK YOU WE HAVE QUESTIONS FROM
SOME MEMBER GARCIA PAULA BY
MISTER MATHIS.
THANK YOUNG GONNA CONTINUE WITH
THE SECTION -- NINE STUFF YOU
JUST SAID THAT.
THEY'RE READY IN THE PROCESS OF
THEIR READY DEVELOPING A PROCESS
AROUND AND THERE WAS IN CONTROL
AND SO ARE WE GETTING AHEAD OF
THAT WITH THIS BILL WOULD BE MY
FIRST QUESTION WHY DO WE NEED TO
GET AHEAD OF THAT -- THERE'S
SOMETHING OUT THAT'S ALREADY
BEING WORKED ON THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
I'D I DON'T BELIEVE WE'RE
GETTING OUT AHEAD OF THE
REGIONAL BOARDS PROCESS BECAUSE
THEY WILL IN REGULATION BRING
ABOUT THIS.
SAME REQUIREMENT FOR A BROADER
SCOPE OF OF POTENTIAL TIMBER
HARVESTING OPERATIONS BUT THESE
CHANGES IN OUR VIEW NEED TO
OCCUR NOW THE REGION FOR THE
REGIONAL BOARD IS.
DOING GOOD WORK -- BUT I THINK
THE LEGISLATURE BY WEIGHING IN
HERE AND PRIORITIZING THESE
SALMONBERRY WATER COURSES THAT
ARE ALREADY IMPAIRED SHOWING
THAT PROGRESS CAN MOVE IN A
PARTICULAR DIRECTION.
WHAT'S THE TIMELINE THAT THEY'RE
EXPECTED TO BE DONE WITH THAT
ASIS I'M NOT CERTAIN THERE IS AN
ESTABLISHED.
TIMELINE FOR COMPLETING THE
PROCESS [inaudible]
AND SO.
YOU ALSO MENTIONED THAT SOME OF
THESE -- HARVEST PLANS ALREADY
HAVE THIS EROSION CONTROL.
PART OF THE PLAN IN THERE
ALREADY BUT SOME DON'T WHY IS IT
THAT SOME DO AND SOME DON'T.
I'M NOT.
AN EXPERT ON EXACTLY WHAT WHICH
THP USER TIMBER HARVESTING PLANS
HAVE TO HAVE CERTAIN EROSION
CONTROL REQUIREMENTS GENERALLY
SPEAKING THERE THEIR SPECIFIC TO
THE THE AREA THAT'S ENVISIONED
FOR HARVEST OF COURSE THERE ARE
THE THREE DIFFERENT KINDS OF
TIMBER HARVESTING PLANTS THE
THEN TNT'S THE WORKING FORCE
MANAGEMENT PLANS.
IN THIS TIMBER HARVESTING PLANTS
EACH HAVE THEIR OWN --
SPECIFICATIONS AND REQUIREMENTS
UNDER THE DIFFERENT REGIONAL
BOARDS I'M SURE THE QUESTION
WOULD BE TO WRITE ARE ANSWERED
BY.
THE THE OPPOSITION.
YES THANK UP SOME IMPRESSIVE
SOLD THE IN TEMPE NON INDUSTRIAL
TO MOMENTUM PLANT DOES HAVE.
A LOOK AT A RUSSIAN AS WELL BUT
IT LOOKS AT IT AS A ONE TIME
BASIS IN THE ONE TIME APPROVAL
AND LESS THAT LANDOWNER DECIDES
TO THEN HARVEST TREES.
THEN IT HAS TO GO BACK AND REDO
THE PLAN TO CONSIDER EROSION
AGAIN BUT IT IT IS LOOKED AT
TEACH BILL LOOKED AT ALL THE
TIME PERIOD.
I THINK OUR CONCERN IS IS THAT
T. H. P. ALL TEACH PLEASE HAVE
THE RUSSIAN CONTROL PLAN.
BUT TEACH PEAS COVER A FEW
HUNDRED ACRES FOR GIVEN PROJECT
THEY DON'T COVER ALL OF AN OF A
LANDOWNER'S PROPERTY.
AN NCMP COVERS UP TO TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED ACRES AND A WORKING
FOREST MANAGEMENT PLAN COVERS UP
TO TEN THOUSAND ACRES.
SO YOU WOULD NOT DO AN EROSION
CONTROL PLAN TO COVER TEN
THOUSAND ACRES IT WOULD BE A
MASSIVE UNDERTAKING A LOT OF
COSTS WHAT YOU WOULD DO IS AN
EROSION CONTROL PLAN. FOR
PROJECT WITHIN THE INDIAN P. OR
WITHIN THE WFMT AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR WITH IT NEEDS
TO BE CHANGES BECAUSE AGAIN.
WHAT HAS BEEN DIFFICULT IS
HAVING FOLKS THAT ARE EXPERTS IN
FORESTRY TELLING US WHAT THE
RULES SHOULD BE WHEN THEY DON'T
KNOW THE RULES IN THE FIRST
PLACE?
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALL OBJECT ON
LETTER FINISHED PLEASE SEVEN US
QUESTION YET THAT HAS THAT HAS
BEEN DIFFICULT FOR US SO WE HAVE
TRIED TO PROVIDE.
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE ON ON ON THE
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
SO.
I'VE SEEN THESE THESE PLANS AND
I CAN TELL YOU THAT I UNDERSTAND
THE MALL BUT I KNOW A LOT OF
WORK GOES INTO THEN WE HAVE A
LOT OF EACH IS IS INCLUDED IN
THERE WE COULD IN THE GEOLOGIST --
THAT THAT YOU'RE OUT THERE AND
IT'S A PROCESS THAT WAS CREATED
BY HUMANS ARE BY NO MEANS DO I
AM I GOING TO BELIEVE THAT IT'S
PERFECT.
BUT IT SEEMS TO BE YOU KNOW
[inaudible]
PRETTY COMPREHENSIVE.
AND THERE MAY BE A ROOMS THAT
NEED TO BE MADE IN THERE BUT I I
DON'T FULLY UNDERSTAND WHY.
WE NEED TO SWITCH WHO IS THE
LEAD AGENCY WHERE THE GEOLOGIST
HAS.
TO HAS TO BE THE ONE TO SIGN
OFTEN ALREADY PART OF THE
PROCESS AND GET TO HAVE A VOICE
AND ARE READY AND SO WHY WE NEED
TO CHANGE THOSE RULES.
SO YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND ANSWER
THAT FOR ME NOW APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION ASSEMBLYMEMBER WE WE
ARE.
ABSOLUTELY WILLING TO TAKE THAT
TECHNICAL SUGGESTION FROM THE
OPPOSITION IN THEIR LETTER.
ABOUT HOW ABOUT THE ROLE THAT
THE STATE GEOLOGIST WOULD PLAY
IN THIS REVIEW OF LOGGING
OPERATIONS ON EXTREME -- OCEAN
HAZARD AREAS I MEAN AGAIN THESE
ARE THESE ARE THE THE TERM IS.
DODD NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED BUT
THE FACT IS THESE ARE AREAS THAT
HAVE AN EXTREME EROSION
POTENTIAL IF THE GEOLOGISTS
LICENSED BY THE STATE ARE
REVIEWING THEM -- THAN THAT CAN
BE.
PART OF THE PROCESS ENVISIONED
BY THIS BILL AND WE'RE PERFECTLY
WILLING.
TO ADDRESS THAT IN TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS AND NATURI SOURCES
SUCH AS THE ANCHOR BECAUSE I'LL
I'LL SEE AGAIN AND NATURAL
RESOURCES I'VE THIS MAKES IT
THERE -- AND I MEAN I I ALSO
WANT TO STOP.
REFERENCING THEN ASKED TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS BECAUSE WHAT YOU
THINK THEIR TECHNICAL I THINK IT
MIGHT.
MINIMIZE OR SHE REALIZED HOW HOW
THE OTHER SIDE IS FILLING ABOUT
THESE AMENDMENTS OUT THERE --
BUT JUST TO BE CLEAR YOU YOU'RE
SAYING THAT YOU'RE WILLING TO
REMOVE THE PART THAT SAYS THAT
THE G. COLLEGES ARE THE FINAL.
SIGN OFF ON ON THESE PLANS.
YES AS THE AUTHOR YES.
OKAY I THANK YOU UP ABOUT THAT.
I WILL SAY THAT YOU KNOW YOU YOU
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS AND
THEY HAVE GONE FROM OPPOSED TO
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED I THINK
THE OPPOSITION THAT YOU HAVE
HERE HAS FOCUS.
ON SECTION -- NINE MULTIPLE
TIMES IT'S THAT THE PART THAT
I'VE BEEN.
FOCUSING ON MYSELF AND SO I HOPE
THAT WE DO THAT PART AND THEN I
HOPE THAT WE FIND A COMPROMISE
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
DEFINITION OR TO ALLOW ME TO RUN
EXTREMELY RELATION.
HACER RATING VERSUS -- WE'RE
SAYING THAT WE ALREADY HAVE A
REGIONAL BOARD GOING TOWARDS --
I THINK THAT THAT'S THE OTHER
OUTSTANDING PIECE THAT'S THAT'S
OUT HERE.
I TO BE ADDRESS AS AS THIS MOVES
FORWARD.
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
AT THIS IN THE COMMITMENT TO
THAT AMENDMENT MOVING FORWARD I
KNOW THAT ONE TAKE CARE OF
EVERYTHING BUT I'M GOING TO GIVE.
MY SUPPORT TODAY LOOKING FOR
THAT AND AND NATURAL RESOURCES
ARE ASKING THE OPPOSITION TO
KEEP WORKING WITH US TO MAKE
SURE WE FIND A COMPROMISE -- MAN
THE WORK HAS HAS BEEN MOVING
HERE -- AND SO WITH THAT I'LL GO
AHEAD AND HANDED OVER TO OUR
OFFICE QUESTION THING.
AS FOR MATHIS FOLLOWED BY MS
FREEMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I'D
LIKE TO A LINE MY COMMENTS
REGARDS TO SECTION NINE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES -- AND ALSO I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THE AMENDMENTS
MADE AS IT COMES TO NATURAL
RESOURCES AND I WILL SEE YOU
THERE -- BUT I'M ALSO FEELING
THE SENSE OF URGENCY THAT THAT'S
BEING STRESS -- BY THE
PROPONENTS OF THIS.
AND I FIND THAT INTERESTING
BECAUSE THERE SEVERAL RECENT
NEWS ARTICLES ABOUT HOW WELL THE
SALMON INDUSTRIES DOING.
SHELL IF.
WE'RE BEING TOLD THERE'S THIS
THIS URGENCYTO GET THIS DONE.
THEN WHY DOES THE PRESS AND AND
ACTUALLY COMMENTS.
FROM THE PROPONENTS THE YOU GUYS
ARE SAYING.
YOU HAVE YOUR URINE DIRE STRAITS
HERE BUT AS RECENTLY AS LAST
YEAR YOU'RE KIND OF BRAGGING
ABOUT HOW WELL THE INDUSTRY'S
DOING SO.
IT'S KIND OF A MIXED SIGNAL.
ON HEY WE'VE GOT TO GET THIS
DONE IMMEDIATELY THIS IS GOING
TO GO FORWARD BUT THE AND I MEAN
I I COULD READ.
THE SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE
ARTICLES ABOUT HOW WELL THE YOU
GUYS OF SAID THE SALMON ARE
DOING SO.
WHAT IS AT OF TERMINUS TO ABOUT
IT I THINK HAVING ONE OR?
TWO GOOD YEARS DOESN'T.
CHANGE THE LONG TERM DECLINE BUT
WITH HIS SENATOR THIS OF
PRACTICES OF FORESTRY HAVE
CHANGED OVER THE DECADES.
YOU'RE USING OLD RESEARCH DATA
TO SHOW.
LEGACY ISSUES EVEN THOUGH THE
PRACTICES OF CHANGE SO THE NEW
ARTICLES TALKING ABOUT GOOD
YEARS OF SALMON.
IN REGARDS TO AT THE SAME TIME
FOR STRETCHES OF CHANGE.
IT IT REALLY MAKES IT
INTERESTING TO TO LOU TO PUT IT
ALL TOGETHER.
WHERE OKAY BEFORE YES THERE WAS
ISSUES BEFORE FOR SHE WAS ON A
LOT DIFFERENTLY?
BEFORE FISHING WAS DONE A LOT
DIFFERENTLY SO HERE WE ARE IN TO
THEM A MODERN AGE OF THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY.
FRESH NEWS ARTICLES OF HOW WALL
THE SEVEN HISTORIES DOING AND
HERE WE ARE.
DEBATING A BILL.
TO GET INTO FORESTRY AND CHANGE
THINGS AND CHANGE SETTLEMENT
EVERYTHING ELSE A LOT OF THIS
BILLS.
VERY GOOD VERY GERMANE AS VICE
CHAIR MENTION FOR IT.
THE URGENCY AND THE PUSH OF LIKE
HEY LET'S GET THIS DONE NOW.
WHEN INTEREST IS DOING WELL
RIGHT NOW IS JUST INTERESTING TO
SEE?
YEAH AND I JUST TO BE CLEAR I
DON'T I'VE NEVER SAID ON THE
RIVER SUGGESTED THAT.
THE TIMBER INDUSTRY IS
RESPONSIBLE. FOR THE IS THAT
DOCTOR WHAT'S CAUSING TO THE
CLIMB THAT'S THE THE DOMINANT OR
THE SOLE FACTOR THAT'S CAUSING
THE CLIENTS ON THE TO ONE PIECE
OF THE PUZZLE BUT I'LL ASK MR
OPPENHEIM TO RESPOND. TO IT.
THANK YOU SOME OF THE MEMBER FOR
THE QUESTION.
THE THE WELCOME NEWS YOU POINT.
TO IS THAT THE SAME IN INDUSTRY
IS BACK FROM THE BRINK WE HAD
FEDERALLY DECLARED FISHERY
DISASTERS IN 201-622-01720
EIGHTEEN WASN'T SO MUCH BETTER.
SO FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A
DECADE THIS INDUSTRY IS ABLE TO
MAKE THE BOTTOM LINE WORK.
I MEAN THAT'S THAT THE FACT THAT
THAT'S A VICTORY WORTHY OF THE
FRONT PAGE OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
CHRONICLE.
IS AN ASTONISHINGLY TELLING SIGN
OF HOW COMPROMISE THE INDUSTRY
HAS BEEN.
SO WE'RE BACK AND FISHERMEN ARE
ABLE TO PAY THE BILLS THEY WERE
SHUT DOWN OUT OF THE CRAB
FISHERY FOR THREE MONTHS THIS
SPRING.
SO WE WERE CELEBRATING BECAUSE
OUR MEMBERS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
SELL THEIR BOOKS.
THE SALMON FISHERY IS BENEFITING
FROM PRECIPITATION IN THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SPRING SEASON THAT
MOOD FISHER THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WE'RE STILL FISHING ON QUOTAS IN
THE KLAMATH MANAGEMENT'S OUT WE
STILL OF HIS OWN AROUND THAT YOU
RIVER THAT IS CLOSE IT'S BEEN
CLOSED FOR DECADES.
SO WE WE HAVE BENEFITS COMING
FROM.
NATURE'S BOUNTY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND LUCKILY HATCHERY
REFORMS THAT ALLOWED US TO MOVE
FISH OUT OF THOSE COMPROMISED
STREAMS AWAY FROM THOSE CREDIT
PREDATION GAUNTLETS BUT YOUR
COLLEAGUE WAS SPEAKING ABOUT
EARLIER.
THERE ARE STILL PARTS OF THE
STATE WHERE YOU CAN'T CATCH FISH
STATE WERE GUIDES RECREATIONAL
ANGLERS AND COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN.
ARE RESTRICTED. TO THE POINT
WHERE IT'S NOT EVEN WORTH BUYING
DIESEL TO GO OUT OPEN THE NORTH
COAST WHERE MOST OF THESE
COMPROMISEDSENTIMENT IMPAIRED
WATER COURSES ARE THERE ARE
STILL PROBLEMS WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS.
AND WE CAN CELEBRATE THE FACT
THAT YOU CAN GO OUT AND BUY
SENATE FOR TWENTY DOLLARS A
POUND SO THE FORTY BUT WE'RE
STILL STRUGGLING AND THIS BILL
IS GOING TO DO A LOT MORE TO
THAT NOTE EVERY INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA STRUCK BECAUSE IT'S
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE OVER.
INDULGENT ON WHAT THE STATE DOES
TO OUR INDUSTRIES.
SOUND THAT'S NOT PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION -- ALSO I'M GONNA
ASK YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD SEVERAL
WILDFIRES.
THAT I'VE.
COMPLETELY IMPACTED -- THINGS
AND HAD MUD SLIDES AND
EVERYTHING ELSE TO DO WITH THOSE
ARE YOU GUYS LOOKING AT THE
NUMBERS AND WITH THAT BECAUSE I
MEAN I KNOW.
ON THE FORESTRY SIDE IN FOR SURE
MANAGEMENT AND EVERYTHING THAT'S
BEEN DISCUSSED WITH WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
THEY'RE LOOKING AT HOW.
TO MITIGATE THE IMPACT OF THE
FOREST FIRES AND KEEP THOSE
THINGS DOWN.
AND THE AREAS -- YOU KNOW YOU
LOOK DOWN SOUTH AND YOU CAN SEE
WHERE WE HAD A FORCE FIRE
FOLLOWED BY A MUD SLIDE.
SO I MEAN ARE WE LOOKING AT
THOSE IMPACTS AS WELL BECAUSE I
HAVEN'T SEEN THAT FULLY
ADDRESSED IN THE LEGISLATION
[inaudible]
THERE ARE.
MANY FACTORS.
RIGHT AND AND ADDRESSING ONE
FACTOR.
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THERE ARE AND
OTHER FACTORS -- AND YOU KNOW
THAT THIS BILL AT LEAST EARLY ON
ONE OF ONE OF THE COMMENTERS
WHAT THE BILL IS THERE IS THERE
A LOT OF ASPECTS TO THE BILL'S
BEEN NARROWED SIGNIFICANTLY.
US ARE NOT GOING TO SOLVE EVERY
PROBLEM IN ONE BILL -- BUT I
KNOW THAT WE ARE ALL UNANIMOUSLY
COMMITTED -- TO TRYING TO
ADDRESS THOSE PARTICULAR ISSUES
IN THOSE DISASTERS BUT BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THIS ISN'T
ALSO A FACTOR.
OKAY.
AND AND CENTER I'M I'M JUST
GONNA GO AND ASK THE THE
QUESTION I THINKS OUT THERE ARE
YOU WILLING TO TAKE.
AMENDMENTS IN REGARDS TO SECTION
NINE OF YOUR BILL.
I I THINK I ANSWERED THAT TO
SOME MEMBER.
CARDS AYE AYE SIR NOW ADDICTED I
SAID WE WOULD TAKE THAT AMOUNT
AND WE TALKED TO HER ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
ABOUT THE GEOLOGIST MISTER CHAIR
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO TABLE THIS
BILL -- FOR A WEEK TO GIVE THE
AUTHOR AN OPPORTUNITY TO BRING
IT BACK WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU FOR THE SUGGESTION.
IF WE HAVE IT ABOUT ACTING
[inaudible]
MRS A WE HAVE A SECOND ON THE
TAPE IS A MOTION AND A SECOND.
TO TO TABLE THE NO NO THE MISTER
A DOCTOR.
YEAH SECOND IT.
WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL ON THE
MOTION A SECOND TO TABLE THE
BILL.
JUST FOR MAYBE TWO IF YOU WANT
INTO IS -- TO BUT OF A MOTION
SECOND.
THE BILL IS DOUBLE REFERRED SO
THAT THAT MAKE THINGS BE
COMPLICATED BUT WE HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE
THAT -- VOTE HERO COMPANIES.
WHICH IS RECOMMENDING A NO VOTE.
THE MOTION SECOND.
MOTION IS TO TAPE -- TO TABLE
THE BILL.
EDUARDO GARCIA GARCIA NO
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING CHOI.
CHOICE I TO GO TO NOW
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN -- CENA GARCIA.
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA NO GLORIA.
KALRA [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS I BLANCA RUBIO.
THE BLANCA RUBIO NO SALAS WOULD.
WOULD NOW.
FROM.
TO FOR AT FORTY FOUR VOTE --
QUESTIONS A ON THE LIST HERE.
FROM MY MRS RUBIO FOLLOWED BY
DOCTOR WOULD.
MINE IS JUST A COMMON IF -- AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR WILLING TO
TAKE THOSE -- AMENDMENTS TO
SECTION NINE IF THAT'S THE CASE
AND THAT WORKS THEN I CAN
SUPPORT THE BILL TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS --
BUT I DO APPRECIATE THE THE WORK
THAT YOU HAVE ALREADY DONE.
YES I I WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FOR WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION I THINK BASED ON WHAT
WE'RE HEARING THE OPPOSITION IS
COME QUITE A WAYS OR YOU'VE COME
COME UP QUITE A WAYS TO MEET
THEM AND OBVIOUSLY DID SOME OF
THE TECHNICAL -- NUANCES OF OF
OF DISAGREEMENT AT THIS POINT I
THINK ARE THINGS THAT I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE LOOKING
SERIOUSLY SERIOUSLY OUT SO --
KNOWING THE BILL'S GOING TO
NATURAL RESOURCES AS WELL AND
BEFORE WE SIT ON THE FLOOR I'M
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS TODAY
WHEN ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION --
YOU KNOW THERE ARE A HUGE NUMBER
AS HAS BEEN SAID MANY TIMES A
HUGE NUMBER REASONS WHY WE HAVE
SEDIMENTATION -- IN OUR STREAMS
THAT AFFECT OUR SALMON BEARING
AREAS -- I THINK RIGHT NOW I
THINK THE SACRAMENTO RIVER --
WITH THE THE IMPACTS OF A CAR
FIRE FOR EXAMPLE THAT'S GOING TO
BE SOMETHING THIS FELT FOR FOR
YEARS.
ON THAT WILL AFFECT -- A LOT OF
TRIBUTARIES AND THINGS THAT ARE
SALMON BEARING UP AND DOWN UP
AND DOWN THE SACRAMENTO RIVER --
NOT MISTER THE FOCUS OF OF THE
CONVERSATION HERE TODAY BUT JUST
ANOTHER ILLUSTRATION OF SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES WE FACE SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND OTHER.
SUPPORT TODAY ON THAT BASIS
THANK YOU.
THE DOCTOR ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I THINK WE'RE MAKING SOME
PROGRESS HERE -- AND IT'S CLEAR
THAT THE AUTHORED THE BILL VIA
THE COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
BEING MADE BOTH BY OPPOSITION
MEMBERS.
ARE BEING TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION WHICH IS WHY.
IN THE DISCUSSIONS WITH YOUR
TEAM -- WE FELT THAT THE DO PASS
AS AMENDED -- YOU'VE
DEMONSTRATED GOOD FAITH TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES YOU'VE
REITERATE IT THAT TODAY AND SO --
WE'RE WE'RE ASKING THAT WE MOVE
THIS BILL TO THE NEXT COMMITTEE
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE A LOT OF
FOLKS.
THAT ARE ON THIS COMMITTEE WILL
BE SEEING YOU AGAIN AND
EXPECTING THOSE CHANGES TO BE
MADE.
SO THERE'S A MOTION.
SECOND MOST RUBIO AND AND
CLOSING COMMENTS I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BECAUSE THE ONE
THING ALL OF YOU FOR THE REALLY
THOUGHTFUL -- DISCUSSIONS THOSE
FOR SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY
AND THOSE WHO ARE INTO -- AND I
THINK -- THE GOOD THE ON THE
POSITIVE SIDE OF THE WE HAVE A
DISCRETE -- DISAGREEMENT WITH
THE TIMBER INDUSTRY WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT I'M GLAD
TO HEAR THAT WE HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
FOR TAKING BOLD ACTION TO MAKE
OUR OCEANS AND OUR WATERWAYS
HEALTHIER SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FROM AGO.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER.
NO GALLAGHER KNOWN.
BIGELOW.
AS AMENDED.
AS AMENDED [inaudible]
NOT VOTING.
I DIDN'T HEAR THAT.
NUMBER NUMBER BIGELOW NOT VOTING.
CHOI NO CHOI KNOWN TO OUR CHIU I
FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA.
KALRA [inaudible]
LEVINE.
HI LEVINE I MATHIS.
NOT VOTING I LOOK FOR TO THE AND
THEN THAT'S NATURAL RESOURCE.
MATHIS NOT VOTING BLANCA RUBIO.
MARCO RUBIO AYE SALAS WOULD.
WOULD I FAR WILL KEEP THAT OPEN
FURTHER BY MEMBER MICHAEL I
DON'T THANK YOU [inaudible]
CENTER NIELSEN.
SPEED.
TWO TWO SIX MOVE THE BILL.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS YOU HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND WAS NIELSEN
AND YOU ALSO A JOY. TO PASS AS
AMENDED RECOMMEND NATION IT'S A
GOOD START AND I'LL BE BRIEF --
I DO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS MOST OF THE MORE
TECHNICAL ONE DOES RELATE TO
ALLOWING TO COUNTIES TO BAND
TOGETHER AND PINE FOR THESE
MONIES.
THESE MONIES ARE CONTINGENT ON
APPROPRIATION OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THEY WOULD BE FOR WATERSHED
RESTORATION IN THE AFFECTED
COUNTIES FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AND AFTER.
A WHILE I WON'T BELABOR IT BUT
LET'S JUST SAY THAT THERE'S A
DEVASTATING IMPACT THAT LAST ON
THESE.
FOREST IN WILD LANDS AND EVEN
THE URBAN INTERFACE LANDS THAT
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED.
IN SOME CASES THE FIRES SO HOT
THAT IT LITERALLY STERILIZERS
THE LAND.
IT CERTAINLY AFFECTS HABITAT.
BOTH AB IN AND AND AND WATER.
FISH FOR EXAMPLE.
AND WE NEED TO GET BACK AND TRY
TO RESTORE AND IN SOME CASES
THIS WILL REQUIRE I BELIEVE SOME
RE PLANT.
BUT WE DO NOT HAVE ANY RESOURCES
TO DO THAT THIS IS AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL WE WOULD ASK YOUR
INDULGENCE FOR THE YES VOTE.
WELL YOU HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND -- THOSE OF SPEAKING IN
FAVOR OF THE A MEASURE PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
YOUR SINGLE PICKY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
OF A YOU A STUDY FROM TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BY THE U. U. S.
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY SHOW THAT
WHILE FIRES HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DOUBLE THE AMOUNT OF SETTLEMENT.
IN A THIRD OF THE LARGEST
WESTERN WATERSHEDS BY.
TWENTY FIFTY IN SOME AREAS SEVEN
IT COULD INCREASE BY A 1000%
POTENTIALLY CARRYING PARASITES
AND HARMFUL METALS AND CHEMICALS
WITH IT FOR THOSE REASONS WE
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
XTC RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA THIS IS PROGRAM IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP IN THE LONG
TERM RESTORATION GOALS IN THE
HEALTH OF OUR WATER SHEDS AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
JONATHAN CLAIM ABOUT THE COUNTY
SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR CHRISTMAS KELLY ON
BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO
REDWOOD COMPANIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. TO THE HOLE
WITH THE ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES HERE IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MARK FRIENDS TO
MAKE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU ANYONE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
I SEE NO ONE BRING BACK TO DISS
OUR QUESTION.
SHALL.
I JUST WANT TO THANK MY SENATOR --
FOR BRING IN THIS -- FORD AND I
THINK IT'S A MUCH NEEDED PROGRAM.
THAT WILL HELP -- YOU KNOW WE'VE
WE'VE EXPERIENCED SOME
DEVASTATING FIRE.
FIRES AS WE ALL KNOW.
IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE
AND YOU KNOW KIND OF HARKENING
BACK TO OUR PREVIOUS DISCUSSION
THIS IS ONE OF THE BIGGER
SOURCES OF WERE SEEN EROSION AND
SEDIMENT GETTING INTO OUR RIVER
SYSTEMS.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THESE
DEVASTATING FIRES AND SO. ONE WE
NEED TO DO THIS IN TERMS OF
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE SOME.
SOME FUNDING TO DO RESTORATION
WORK -- YOU KNOW IN THESE AREAS
WHERE WE'VE HAD THAT --
DEVASTATING WILD WILDFIRE.
IN ALSO TRY AND DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO PREVENT AND YES SENATORS
BEEN.
IN A BIG ADVOCATE FOR THAT AS
WELL HOW WE PREVENT AS WE NEED
GREATER FORESTRY MANAGEMENT --
YOU KNOW THROUGHOUT THROUGHOUT
OUR FORCED IT LANDS WERE DOING
SOME OF THAT WORK AND BUT WE
SHOULD NOT DO IS IS.
PROVIDED A A AN ADDITIONAL
IMPEDIMENT TO DOING SOME OF THAT --
MATCHING IN FORESTRY MANAGEMENT
WORK SO THANK THE SENATOR ASKED.
OF ASK MY COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY OKAY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS IN.
NO ONE WE DO HAVE A MOTION
SECOND MANAGEMENT.
ALL RIGHT HAPPY TO HI THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU DO HAVE A DO PASS
AS AMENDED.
ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENT SAUCE FOR
ROLL CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA HI
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GALLAGHER AYE
GALLAGHER AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU.
CHU AYE FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I GLORIA.
KALRA.
LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I TALK A RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO HIGH SALAS WOOD
[inaudible] SIX THE CENTER WILL
DETERMINE THANK YOU MEMBERS.
SB THREE NINETY FIVE CENTER ARE
TO LET.
YOU HAVE A DO PASSED WITH
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND PLEASE
BEGIN.
MOVE THE BILL AS AMENDED.
MOTION SIR BIGELOW.
THE SECOND WAS SLOWING SO WITH
THIS BILL [inaudible]
NO NO.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
AND A SECOND BY DOCTOR JOE.
TO CONTINUE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU A GERMAN
GARCIA AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
THANK YOU. FOR TAKING THIS TIME
OUT FOR ME TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH ME ON
THIS BILL.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS -- THIS
BILL SB THREE NINETY FIVE KNOWN
AS THE WILDLIFE TRAFFIC SAFETY
ACT REQUIRES FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION TO DEVELOP A PILOT
PROGRAM. TO PERMIT THE SALVAGE
OF CERTAIN LARGE GAME MAMMALS
KILLED BY A VEHICLE COLLISIONS.
AND REQUIRES A DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILD WILDLIFE TO
COLLECT COMPILE AND MAKE
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC THE
REPORTING OF DATA.
OF WILDLIFE VEHICLE COLLISIONS.
EACH YEAR IT IS ESTIMATED THAT
OVER TWENTY THOUSAND DEAR ALONE
ARE KILLED ON CALIFORNIA
ROADWAYS.
EVEN MORE ALARMING ACCORDING TO
THE DATA GATHERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
OVER THE LAST SIX YEARS
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT THOUSAND
LARGE GAME ANIMAL COLLISIONS
HAVE CONSUMER HAVE RESULTED IN
FIFTEEN HUNDRED INJURIES.
AND AT LEAST TWENTY FOUR
FATALITIES TO MOTORISTS AND
PASSENGERS ALIKE.
THIS IS A SERIOUS ISSUE.
AND MORE DATA IS NEEDED TO
CREATE SAFER LARGE GAME ANIMALS
COLLISION A CALIFORNIA ARE MULTI
FACETED PROBLEM THAT CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA HAS NO RESPONSE TO
MITIGATE THESE AVOIDABLE THREATS
TO OUR PUBLIC SAFETY. FOR ONE
THERE IS NO MECHANISM TO TRACK
OR MAP HISTORICALLY DANGEROUS
AREAS.
WE KNOW THAT THEIR THAT THESE
AREAS DO EXIST IN THE STATE WERE
MOTORIST AND LARGE GAME ANIMALS
SPECIFICALLY DEER ELK ANTELOPE.
ARE MORE LIKELY TO COME INTO
CONTACT.
BUT WE DO NOT HAVE ACTIONABLE
DATA TO CHANGE THE OUTCOMES
[inaudible]
SECONDLY.
CALIFORNIA FISH AND GAME CODE
SECTION. TWO THOUSAND THREE
POINT FIVE PROHIBITS INDIVIDUALS
FROM REMOVING ANIMALS OUT OF THE
ROADWAY BECAUSE OF THIS.
ANIMALS ARE USUALLY LEFT IN THE
ROAD.
AFTER THE COLLISION THIS IN TURN
LEADS TO A SECONDARY HAZARD AND
MORE COLLISIONS.
NOT TO MENTION THE ADDED COST TO
CALTRANS TO EVENTUALLY CLEAN UP
THE ROAD BECAUSE OF THE ACCIDENT.
BY MARRYING THAT LEGISLATION
THAT IS ALREADY IN PLACE IN MANY
STATES INCLUDING IDAHO MONTANA
OREGON WASHINGTON.
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY FIVE
WILL ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS.
WILL REQUIRE THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION. TO DEVELOP A WEB
BASED PORTAL.
THAT WOULD ALLOW USERS TO LOG
INFORMATION IN REGARDS TO LARGE
GAME MEMEL COLLISIONS AT THE
SAME TIME DELIVER PERMITS FOR
THE TAKE OF THESE LARGE GAME AND
MAMMALS.
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED IN
PREVIOUS COMMITTEES AND AND I'M
SURE YOU HAVE THE SAME QUESTION
ABOUT ALLOWING MOTORISTS TO
DISPATCH.
INJURED ANIMALS ON THE ROADWAY.
WITH THE HELP OF THE WATER PARKS
AND AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE WE
HAVE AMENDED THIS PROVISION OUT
OF THE BILL.
RECENT AMENDMENTS ALSO GIVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE COMMISSION
TO BE ABLE TO DETERMINE THE
GEOGRAPHICAL SIZE OF THE PILOT
PROGRAM.
THAT IS SB THREE NINETY FIVE AND
ONCE AGAIN I EMPHASIZE A PILOT
PROGRAM THAT IS.
THREE NINETY FIVE THIS BILL WILL
IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY ON OUR
ROADWAYS AND SAVE THOUSANDS OF
DEER AND WILDLIFE. FOR ROAD
RELATED DEATHS IN THE FUTURE.
THIS BILL HAD RECEIVED NO VOTES
NO NO VOTE HAS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION. FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY.
I HAVE -- DOCTOR FRAZIER
CHILLING FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE AND POLICY
AT UC DAVIS.
AND BILL GAINES REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA DEAR ASSOCIATION TO
ANSWERING TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE REGARD TO THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR PLEASE.
CLOSE THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME.
TO TESTIFY HERE TODAY -- I AM
PHASES SHOWING AT DEPARTMENT OF
ART AND SCIENCE OF POLICY UC
DAVIS I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
ROAD ECOLOGY CENTER EASY DAVIS --
WE STUDY ROAD IMPACTS -- ON
NATURE WILDLIFE ECOLOGY -- ALSO
THE ORGANIZER FOR THE
INTERNATIONAL CONFERENCE A
CONFERENCE ON ECOLOGY AND
TRANSPORTATION WHICH IS THE
PRIMARY CONFERENCE IN THIS FIELD --
IN THE WORLD.
AND WE HAVE THE LARGEST LONGEST
RUNNING WILDLIFE AND CRASH
REPORTING SYSTEM IN THE U. S.
THAT'S BEEN GOING FOR THE LAST
TEN YEARS.
AND WE'VE COLLECTED ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND RECORDS IN
CALIFORNIA -- WALLET VEHICLE
COLLISIONS.
THE MONTH WE GET DATA REQUESTS
FROM CALTRANS COOK CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE --
OTHER AGENCIES AND CONSULTANTS
WHO ARE PLANNING FOR WILDLIFE A
VEHICLE COLLISION MITIGATION TO
PROTECT DRIVER SAFETY AND TO
PROTECT WILDLIFE.
STATE FARM INSURANCE ESTIMATES
THAT THERE ABOUT.
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND COLLISIONS
WITH DEAR PER YEAR THE RESULT IN
A CLAIM.
IN OTHER STATES.
ONLY ONE IN FOUR CLAIMS ARE
ACTUALLY REPORTED AB.
SO THEIR ESTIMATES FOR MOST
OTHER STATES IS THAT IF YOU HAVE.
TWENTY TO THIRTY THOUSAND CLAIMS
YOU'VE GOT ABOUT EIGHTY TO A
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACTUAL
COLLISIONS BECAUSE NOT ALL
COLLISIONS ARE REPORTED.
MEANING THAT WE HAVE ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DEAD DEER PER
YEAR ON THE ROADWAYS IN
CALIFORNIA.
OUR WALLET VEHICLE COLLISION
CRASH REPORTING SYSTEM RUN
THROUGH A WEB PORTAL CAN BE USED
ON A SMARTPHONE OR TABLET A
DESKTOP -- COULD BE MODIFIED TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THIS ACT.
IF IF -- THE STATE WANTED TO
CHOOSE A LOWER COST OPTION THAN
THAN INVENTING A NEW SYSTEM --
AND IT ALSO WOULD ALLOW THE
REPORTING OUT OF THESE DATA TO
BE CONTINUOUSLY USED IN
AUTOMATICALLY USED BY
RESPONSIBLE AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
OUR SYSTEM BECAUSE IT'S BEEN
GOING ON FOR A WHILE IT'S HELPED
INFORM THE DEVELOPMENT OF
SIMILAR SYSTEMS AND OTHER STATES
INCLUDING IDAHO'S.
AND NOW WE'RE IN A POSITION TO
BORROW FROM THEIR SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS TO COMBINE COLLECTING
MORE DATA ABOUT WHILE LIKE
VEHICLE COLLISIONS.
AND ALLOWING PEOPLE TO LEGALLY --
RECOVER MADE FROM THE CARCASSES
FROM THOSE CRASHES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BILL GAINES
THAT REPRESENT CALIFORNIA DEAR
ASSOCIATION ON THIS ISSUE THAT
THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL. ONE
IN SIXTEEN CAR ACCIDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA INVOLVE WILDLIFE.
YOU HEARD THAT THE SENATOR
MENTIONED THAT -- FIFTEEN
THOUSAND FIFTEEN HUNDRED
ACCIDENTS THE CLAIM TWENTY FOUR
LIVES HERE CALIFORNIA IN THE
LAST SIX YEARS WELL CORNY CH
BEING THE LAST TWO YEARS ALONE
THERE'S BEEN.
ABOUT TWELVE PEOPLE KILLED IN
OUR STATE WITH COLLISIONS WITH
BIG GAME ANIMALS.
THESE ARE AVOIDABLE THREATS TO
THE SAFETY OF OUR PUBLIC AND TO
THE LONG TERM HEALTH OF OUR
WILDLIFE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY ARE AVOIDABLE.
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY FIVE
WOULD ADDRESS THESE RISKS IN
SEVERAL WAYS FIRST OF ALL WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND GAME TO CREATE A CELLPHONE
FRIENDLY APP SIMILAR TO THE WAY
ZAP THAT ANY OF YOU PROBABLY
HAVE ON YOUR PHONE NOW TO
REPORTING ACCIDENTS IN VARIOUS
PROBLEMS ON THE ROADWAYS.
A SIMILAR ACT WOULD MAKE IT EASY
FOR CALIFORNIA'S MOTORISTS
REPORT WHERE THESE ACCIDENTS
WITH BIG GAME ARE HAPPENING.
THE DATA IS THE BIG THING THAT
WE NEED TO PREVENT FUTURE
ACCIDENTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH THIS DATA AGENCIES CAN
PARTNER WITH ENTITIES LIKE YOU
KNOW THERE SIR CALIFORNIA DAVIS
THE BETTER PREDICT ROADKILL HOT
SPOT.
AND CONTRIBUTING FACTORS TO
EVALUATE THE PLACEMENT OF FUTURE
WILDLIFE CROSSINGS AND OTHER.
ACTIONS THAT CAN REDUCE FUTURE
ACCIDENTS AND PROMOTE PUBLIC
SAFETY.
OVER THE LONG TERM TO ENCOURAGE
REPORTING SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY FIVE ALSO WOULD ALLOW.
THE SALVAGE OF BIG GAME ANIMALS
INCLUDING DEER ELK ANTELOPE AND
WILD PIG. FOR PERSONAL HUMAN
CONSUMPTION.
THE ISSUE APPROACHING THE OTHER
STATES IDAHO OREGON WASHINGTON
AND MONTANA.
WHO HAVE PROGRAMS ALREADY IN
PLACE I HAVE SEEN NO NOTABLE
INCREASE IN POACHING AS A RESULT
OF SIMILAR PROGRAMS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY UNDER WAY IN THEIR
STATES?
SYMBOL THREE NINETY FIVE WOULD
IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY AND
PROTECT OUR WILDLIFE OVER THE
LONG TERM.
IT WOULD STOP THE NEEDLESS WASTE
OF LARGE ANIMALS KILLED ON OUR
ROADWAYS BY ALLOWING THE SALVAGE
OF WILD GAME MEAT FOR THOSE IN
NEED OR FOR THOSE WHO SIMPLY
ENJOY HEALTHY FREE RANGE ORGANIC
FOOD SOURCES IN BASEBALL THOSE
REASONS I RETURN AYE VOTE TODAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR THIS MEASURE.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
CHIU NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARKEDLY
WITH CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL ALSO
REFEREED REPRESENTING THE CALOR
WETLANDS AND WATERFOWL KENNEL
COUNCIL.
AS WELL AS THE TULARE BASIN
WETLANDS ASSOCIATION AND WE DO
SUPPORT THE BILL WE CONTINUE TO
ALSO URGED THE AUTHOR TO
CONSIDER ADDING OTHER SPECIES TO
THE LIST -- THE STATE OF IDAHO
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER THEY HAVE
ABOUT FORTY PLUS SPECIES ON
THEIR LIST SO THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN ROY GROUP OF
REPRESENT A CALIFORNIA RIFLE
PISTOL ASSOCIATION DAY OFF
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER WELL CHEAP FILM
FOUNDATION CONGRESSIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION IN
THE ROCKING ON ELK FOUNDATION
ALL STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
THOSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE.
SEE NO ONE WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND TOPPING BACK FOR
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- FOR FOR
THIS BILL THAT YOU KNOW IS IT.
INTERESTING BUT ALL IT IT'S
DEALING WITH A REAL ISSUE I'VE
GOT MY OWN CONCERNS ABOUT IT
THAT I'VE I'VE SHARED WITH YOUR
YOUR STAFF -- I APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE PUTTING INTO IT
I THINK THAT WE KNOW THAT APPS --
ARE OUT THERE THAT MAKE IT EASY
TO REPORT THINGS HAPPEN ON THE
ROADWAY.
YOU KNOW SAID ON WAYS AND THERE
ARE SO MANY OTHER WAYS TO DO
THAT AND AND SO I THINK THIS IS
A POSITIVE THING BECAUSE WE DO
WANT TO KNOW WHERE ANIMALS ARE
BEING HIT -- TO TO HELP WITH
WILDLIFE CROSSINGS AND AND
WILDLIFE CORRIDORS WHICH I CARE
A GREAT DEAL ABOUT -- I DO SHARE
THE CONCERNS ABOUT -- WHETHER
THIS INCENTIVIZE IS ANY TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR I KNOW THAT YOU'VE
STATED -- IN OTHER STATES THAT
HASN'T BEEN.
A PROBLEM -- BUT I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT A TAKING IS NECESSARY FOR
DOING THE REPORTING.
AND I THINK THAT THE REPORTING
CAN ALSO MAKE SURE THAT THE
ANIMAL IS SAFELY -- TAKEN FROM
WHEREVER IT'S BEEN HIT -- AND
ALSO COULD BE -- IF IT IS
MORTALLY WOUNDED -- MAYBE COULD
GET BETTER CARE OR TREATMENT
WHILE IT TODD.
EITHER CONVALESCENCE OR OR DOES
NOT -- IF IT'S DONE BY BY
PROFESSIONALS -- AND ALSO MAYBE
EVEN SAFER FOR PEOPLE ON THE
ROADWAY WHO WOULD BE SPENDING
TIME -- DID YOU KNOW TAKING THAT
ANIMALS SO I THE I GOT THOSE
CONCERNS -- LIKELY WILL VOTE NO
TODAY I WILL KEEP AN OPEN MIND
AS IT COMES TO THE FLOOR AS IS
CHANGES ARE MADE OF MORE
INFORMATION COMES TO ME THAT TO
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION -- AND I
DO RESPECT THAT THE WORKING
APPROACH THAT YOU'RE TAKING TO
THAT THIS ISSUE IF I DON'T END
UP ON EXACT SAME PLACE THAT THAT
YOU DO.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
THAT'S ALL I CAN ASK OF I KNOW
THAT -- STAFFERS IS TALK WITH
YOUR OFFICE AND I APPRECIATE THE
TIME YOU'VE GIVEN GIVEN TO US --
MY LAW ENFORCEMENT BACKGROUND
HAD BROUGHT ME TO THIS BILL
EOPLE VAST HOW I GOT INVOLVED
IN BECAUSE OF MY LAW ENFORCEMENT
BACKGROUND SHERMAN WITH THE
MOTHER ABOUT POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AND I SAW THIS IS A IS A PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUE AND THEN IT
INVOLVED IN AS I GOT DEEPER AND
DEEPER INTO IT AND MET WITH A
FISH WILDLIFE AND MET WITH THE
MEMBERS THE COMMISSION AND AND
AND I REALIZED THAT -- IN
SPEAKING WITH THE HIGHWAY PATROL
AND SO.
ONE THAT IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT
THIS BILL GO FORWARD BECAUSE OF
THE FACT THAT SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
KILLED OUR HIGHWAYS AND I CAN
IMAGINE.
OF A VAN FULL OF OF KIDS IN THE
FAMILY IN AND OUT JUMP TO DEAR
AND IT GOES OFF THE HIGHWAY AND
DOWN THE ROADWAY -- ANY COULD
ABORT BEEN AVOIDED PERHAPS WITH
SIGNAGE IT COULD'VE BEEN AVOIDED
WITH THE LIGHTING IT COULD HAVE
BEEN AVOIDED WITH EVEN EVEN A AN
ALERT ON A RADIO -- SOME WAY TO
ALERT THE FAMILIES AND AS YOU
KNOW WE'RE APPROACHING THE
FOURTH OF JULY AND AND FAMILIES
TO BE OUT.
IN AND OUT IN THE WILDERNESS
AREA SO IT'S IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS A PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUE -- BUT ALONG WITH
THAT WE FIND THAT -- THERE'S
REASON TO TO TAKE IN AND TO FEED
A LOT OF HOMELESS PEOPLE OUT
THERE AND IT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL
OUR RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT.
FAMILY AFTER FAMILY -- IT'S BEEN
PROVIDED FOOD THAT THEY WOULD
NORMALLY HAVE SO THAT SHE ISSUE
THE OTHER THING THAT THAT I WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT AND I'M SURE YOU
ARE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBERS POACHING.
THAT IS AGAINST THE LAW THIS
BILL ADDRESSED THAT BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION THEMSELVES WILL BE
ABLE TO PIGGY BACK ON THIS THING
AND MAKE SURE THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN.
SO THE LARGER THERE SO WE TRY TO
GET ALL THE ELEMENTS THAT THAT --
OPPOSITIONS BROUGHT THAT'S WHY
WE WORK WITH THE THE AMENDMENTS
AND SO ON AND SO I'M HOPING IN
THE FUTURE WHEN IT DOES I HIT
THE FLOOR YOU'LL YOU'LL BE WITH
THAT ON ON THE ON THAT.
AND I DON'T THINK THERE'S A
SINGLE BILL OUT THERE THAT'S
PERFECT BECAUSE THERE ARE
CERTAIN ELEMENTS THAT ARE PLUS A
COUPLE OF THAT OUR MINUS.
AND WHEN THE PLUS OUTWEIGH AND
THAT FOR YOUR VOTE COMES ACROSS
AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A DOCTOR YOU
HAVE QUESTION FOLLOWED BY MY
QUESTION.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND THE THING
SENATOR I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL -- BUT I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS NUMBER ONE IS THAT THE
WHEN THE THE ANYMORE SO -- HIT.
CAN BE SALVAGED BY.
UP.
THE A MORE TO RESTORE ANYBODY
ELSE WHO HAPPENED.
TO DISCOVER WHAT THE THE THE THE
ISSUE IMAGINED THE HACKED AND
TAKES PLACE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT BEEN HAPPENING IN THE PAST.
IS THE TRAFFIC BACKS UP TO GET
IS AGAINST THE LAW FOR YOU TO
GET OUT OF YOUR CAR YEAH IN DRAG
THE ANIMAL ACROSS THE ROAD WHEN
THERE'S TRAFFIC COMING ON BOTH
SIDES YES THAT IS AGAINST THE
LAW I WROTE SAID THAT.
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE IS SAID IT
AND EVERYONE KNOWS THAT SO --
THAT'S WHY -- IF WE CAN AVERT
THE ACTION WOULD BE PROACTIVE
HERE SO IF THE CITED WAS THERE
IN ULTIMATELY THIS IS THE GOAL
THIS IS THE GOAL. TO GATHER
ENOUGH DATA SO WE CAN CREATE A
BRIDGE WAY SO IF WE KNOW THAT
THIS HERDS OF DEER AND ELK
WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE.
YOU CAN IMAGINE A V. SHAPED --
FENCING THAT WILL TAKE THAT THE
ANIMALS OVER THE THE ROADWAY AND
ON TO THE OTHER SIDE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS MONEY
WE HAVE A TAPPED INTO IT TO
CREATE THAT BRIDGE WAY AND SO
WITH THE DATA THE INFORMATION WE
COULD SAY SPECIFICALLY.
THIS IS WHERE IT'S HAPPENING AND
EVENTUALLY WE COULD HAVE THESE
BRIDGE WAYS ACROSS THE STATE --
WHICH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WILL HELP FINANCE AND IT DOESN'T
AFFECT US BECAUSE IT IS PUBLIC
SAFETY AND IT'S HAZARDOUS AND SO
THAT'S WHY CALTRANS HIGH WITH
THE TROUT EVERYBODY'S ON BOARD
WITH THIS.
AND WE'RE GOING TO AVOID A LOT
OF FATALITIES AND A LOT OF
INJURIES WITH THIS.
YES.
I DO REALIZE THAT THAT THE VALUE
OF THE DATA THAT THE LOCATION
AND ALL KIND OF BY ANIMALS AS A
TRUST SO SO THAT YOU CAN.
CREATE -- HIGH -- EXTEND EXTENT
AREAS -- CAM THE CONSIDERED
DUFFEL WAR GREETINGS AND SUCH --
CROSSED ROLLED WHAT PAST
PASSAGEWAY FOR THE ANIMALS --
HOWEVER I'M SPEAKING NOW WHY
HERE THAT THE IT IS ILLEGAL FOR
THE MORE THERE IS TO GET OUT AND
TRY TO MOVE US ALL I WOULD NOT
BE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT
THE IF I HIT IT.
IN ALL.
BLOODY THING -- IRAQ KERRY SO
THAT'S WHY WHO SCHOOL NOSTALGIE
THAT ANYMORE AND THE COMMITTEE
TO EAT.
ON SOME WILL CONSUME WELL IT
IMMEDIATE -- WOULD HAPPEN IT'D
GO TO YOUR CELLPHONE REPORT THE
COLLISION CALTRANS ALERTED HIGH
WITH CHOCOLATE AND ALERTED
FACIAL WELL GAME OF THE GAME'S
ALERTED.
AND THEY WOULD COME OUT AND AND
THEY WOULD TAKE THE THE REMAINS --
FOR FOR THE CHARITABLE CITED IN
FEEDING FAB CASTLE FIGHT HAS
BEEN IT WAS SELF PROHIBITED THAT
KIND OF ACTION WAS -- NOT ALLOW
THAT IS CORRECT I SEE OKAY NOW
SECOND QUESTION IS THAT THE UP
WITH THE A POTENTIAL -- DATA.
WITH THE LIMITED THE ABILITY
WITH THE NO FOUR ON ALL WHILE --
DEAL ONE NIGHT REPORTING
MECHANISM MIGHT HAVE BEEN A
LITTLE BIT THE US FLOOR WHILE
LAST AND ACCURATE THE HOWEVER --
THROUGH ROOMREMOVE ALL OF THOSE
SO NOT ANYMORE SO -- HIGHWAY
PATROL WAR WOULD OF HAD THE
ALREADY.
OUR INFORMATION OF WHERE THOSE
ACCIDENTS SO.
I'M MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
HUMAN -- OF FATALITIES WHEN THEY
HIT THE ANIMALS SO IGHT IN ALL
THE YOU MENTIONED THAT OF TAR
PAPER WILL KILL THE IN A YEAR IS
THAT THE TOTAL NUMBER NAM NUMBER
OF A WAS SELF FOR ITO ONE MONTH
THOUGH.
OUR REPORT WAS OVER OAK SHOVEL
YEARS BUT ONE TO TELL IS ONE TOO
MANY.
YES -- ARE AND AND THEN ON WHY
NOT -- IF WE A NEW WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE DATA WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
SYSTEM THE COMMISSION DIDN'T
HAVE THE INFORMATION WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE BILL.
SO NOW WE GO FORWARD WITH THIS
AND THIS IS BEING PROACTIVE IN A
LOT OF A LOT OF RESPONSES BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY THE THE BILL
WILL OPEN UP THE DOOR. TO BRING
AWARENESS HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO THIS TYPE OF
FIDELITY AND I'VE GOTTEN A LOT
OF CALLS FROM MY DISTRICT WHICH
IS IN THE GREATER LOS ANGELES
ORANGE COUNTY AREA.
THEY ASKED AGAIN WHY DID I GET
INVOLVED I GO BACK TO PUBLIC
SAFETY BUT THE RESEARCH SHOWS
AND AND THIS PILOT PROGRAM BY
THE WAY IT'S GONNA TOUCH SOME OF
THE AFFECTED AREAS OF CALIFORNIA
MORE SO.
THAN THE CITIES OF LOS ANGELES
AND SO ON BUT SO IT'S NOT ACROSS
THE STATE TO THE COMMISSION WILL
BE ABLE TO CHOOSE.
THE AREAS WHERE THEY'VE HAD DATA
FROM THE PAST AND AND GO ON TOP
OF THAT.
SO THIS WAY IT'LL BE EFFECTIVE
IT WILL BE UPDATED AND THE OTHER
THING ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEMBER IT --
BRINGS A COMMUNICATIONS CLOSER
TOGETHER SO THEN WHEN THAT ONE
CALL GOES OUT IT AFFECTS
EVERYONE AND TO EVERYONE WILL BE
ACTING QUICKLY.
OKAY HELLO MY FINAL QUESTION IS
THAT THE IN THE STATE SO WHERE
ARE THEY HAVE ALREADY COLLECTED
THE DATA AND UP. TO A AND MORE
ARE COSTING COOLEY BRIDGES AND
THE SO THAT WOULD REQUIRE A LOT
ABOUT FENCING AROUND US SO THAT
THE ONLY PASSAGE WAY SO.
YOU KNOW THEY FIND THAT THEY
MAKE CROSS SO -- DO YOU KNOW
THROUGH THE ANIMAL BEHAVIOR WITH
A DOSE OF BREACHES SO -- ACROSS
WASTE WERE SUCCESSFULLY USED BY
THE ANYMORE.
BUT WITH YOUR INDULGENCE I'LL
ANSWER THAT.
AND THAT IS A IT IS A VERY
SUCCESSFUL MITIGATION APPROACH
IS TO BUILD LAND BRIDGES
WILDLIFE OVER CROSSINGS THEY
COME WITH DIFFERENT NAMES.
ARE THE FIRST ONE WAS BUILT IN
CALIFORNIA IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA LAST OCTOBER -- VERY
MUCH UNDER THE RADAR BUT THERE'S
SO FAR THERE'S NO BIG ONE OVER A
HIGHWAY BUT IN OTHER WESTERN
STATES ACTUALLY A PRETTY MUCH
EVERY OTHER WESTERN STATE.
SET MAYBE ORGAN THERE ARE
WILDLIFE OVER CROSSINGS BECAUSE
THEY ARE VERY EFFECTIVE FROM A
WHILE LIKE BEHAVIOR POINT OF
VIEW SO THERE THEY DO WORK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IF I MAY ASK -- MISTER BILL
GATES TO ALSO CUT THAT PLEASE.
WHAT SPECIFICALLY ON ON WHAT
DOCTOR FRAZIER WAS COMMENTING ON
BUT -- YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
AGENCIES CALTRANS C. H. B. AND
OTHERS THAT MAY BE PICKING UP
THESEANIMALS AND I WAS THERE
NOT REQUIRED REPORT AND OFTEN
THEY DON'T REPORT ON WHERE THOSE
COLLISIONS ARE TAKING PLACE.
THIS BILL WILL HELP FIX THAT BY
REQUIRING AGENCIES THAT IF THERE
ARE THE ONES TO PICK UP THE
ANIMAL THE REPORT.
FROM WHERE THOSE SPOTS A RAT AS
WELL SO AND IT WOULD ALLOW
EITHER THE THE THE MOTORIST THAT
STRUCK THE ANIMAL.
IF IT'S SAFE FOR HIM OR HER TO
GO OUT AND AND TO SALVAGE AT
ANIMAL ALLOW THEM TO BUT THEY
DON'T HAVE TO BE THE ONE THAT
STRUCK IT IF THERE'S A A A A OF
FRESH ADAM ON THE SIDE OF THE
ROAD THAT THAT ANOTHER MOTORIST
COMES ACROSS.
YOU KNOW THEY CAN GO AHEAD AND
SALAS AT ANIMALS WELL OF COURSE
BUT THEY HAVE TO GET THE PERMITS
WHICH IS WHERE WE GET THE DATA.
RIGHT.
WE HAVE QUESTION FROM US SOME
MEMBERSHIP.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE FOCUS
ON THE PUBLIC SAFETY AND TRYING
TO IDENTIFY HOT SPOTS WHERE WE
MIGHT.
SEE A SPIKE IN THESE ACCIDENTS --
MUCH IS THE ANIMAL LIFE THAT
WE'RE LOSING BUT THE HUMAN LIFE
WE HAVE AN ELK AND A CAR
COLLIDED TO PRETTY BAD SITUATION
THE OUT THERE.
OFTENTIMES.
IN SO BUT THIS BILL GOES BE ON
COLLECTING DATA AND I THINK THAT
THAT PIECE AND HAVING THE AGENCY
SPEAK TO EACH OTHER IS.
AN IMPORTANT PIECE BUT THAT
INCLUDES THE TAKE PART THERE
WHICH I HAVE.
CONCERNS WITH AS WELL AS SIMILAR
TO WHAT MY COLLEAGUE HAS
ITERATED EARLIER AND SO WHY ARE
WE NOT LIMITING THIS BILL TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY PART OF THE DATA.
ON AND THE AGENCY SPEAKING TO
EACH OTHER I AND WHERE WE
INCLUDING THAT THE TAKE IN HERE
AND I'VE NO I'VE HEARD THAT
CHARITABLE.
DISCUSSION COME IN HERE BUT THAT
THAT'S NOT SUFFICE TO ME THERE'S
LOTS OF OTHER WAYS I WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE SURE HOUSING THE
HOMELESS AND HELPING TO TAKE
CARE OF THEM ARE.
PROVIDING THEM WITH JOBS THAT
PAY THEM A LITTLE WEIGHT AND SO
FORTH BUT WHY WHY NOT JUST
LIMITED. TO TO THE AGENCIES TO
TALKING TO EACH OTHER TO THE
DATA BEING COLLECTED.
AND THE PUBLIC SAFETY SAFETY
ASPECT THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
CREATE BETTER PLANS FOR THE
HUMANS AND THE ANIMALS ON THE
ROADS.
WHAT THIS IS EXACTLY WHY THE
BILL IS THERE ASSEMBLY WOMAN TO
BRING EVERYBODY TOGETHER AND
BRING AWARENESS TO IT IMAGES
OPENS THE DOOR SO AS I SAID IT'S
NOT A PERFECT BILL BUT IT'S A
DOOR OPENER? TO SAVE LIVES
PREVENT ACCIDENTS AND THIS IS
THE FIRST STEP AND SO IT IS A
COMBINATION OF THINGS BUT THE
COMMISSION AS I HAD MENTIONED
THE COMMISSION THAT WILL BE IN
CHARGE OF OVERSEEING THIS.
AND THAT'S A PILOT PROGRAM SO
THEY'LL THEY HAVE THE POWER TO
EXPAND IT -- IN AND SHUT IT DOWN
ON SOME AREAS AND EXPANDED TO
SOME AREAS WHO HAVE GOT TO GIVE
THE COMMISSION THAT OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THAT.
AND WITH THE DATA THAT COMES AND
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO GET BACK TO
US IN A REPORT BACK TO US AND
SEE HOW WE CAN EXPAND IT. TO GET
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON
CERTAIN AREAS.
KING ANSWER DOUBLE WIRE WE
INCLUDING THE TAKE WHY IS THAT
TAKE PART IMPORTANT THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT'S NOT LIMITING IT. TO
DATA.
INTO CHILD HAVE TO HAVE TWO
SEPARATE BILLS -- AND THEY WOULD
EVENTUALLY JOIN TOGETHER YOU GET
PRETTY HARD TO HAVE ONE WITHOUT
THE OTHER.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT PART
THING TO ME WHY I NEED TO TAKE
FOR FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
[inaudible]
MONITOR.
SO -- MOST OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE TERMS WERE USING
CALTRANS HEATS P. IS REFERRING
TO STATE HIGHWAYS BUT THE
MAJORITY OF ACCIDENTS A PROBABLY
A NON STATE HIGHWAYS.
AND WE STILL NEED TO KNOW ABOUT
THOSE AREAS.
ARE IN THE MAJORITY OF ACCIDENTS
WHERE COLLISION WITH WILDLIFE
AREN'T REPORTED.
AND SO IF WE WANT TO FIND OUT
WHERE THOSE ARE IN TO DISCOVER
THE THE LEVEL OF IMPACT WE NEED
THE PUBLIC INVOLVEMENT.
AND THERE'S OTHER WAYS -- IN
SWEDEN THEY REQUIRE THE PUBLIC
TO REPORT A COLLISION WITH AN
ANIMAL BUT SINCE WE DON'T HAVE
THAT IS HOW DO WE ENCOURAGE A
VOLUNTARY REPORTING.
AND THIS IS ONE WAY -- I'M NOT
SURE WHAT OTHER WAYS THERE ARE
BUT THIS IS ONE WAY IS TO REWARD
WITH MEAT SALVAGING FROM THE
ANIMAL IT'S BEEN HIT.
AND WHY NOT JUST FOLLOW THE
SIMILAR PROGRAM ASSN FOOD AND
JUST TO MANDATE THAT WE HAVE TO
REPORT -- I'M I WOULD THINK THAT
WAS FINE THAT'S A DIFFERENT ROAD
TO CLIMB -- AND MAYBE THAT'S THE
END OF NEXT YEAR THE YEAR AFTER
BUT IN IN OTHER WESTERN STATES
PROVIDING THIS KIND OF REWARD
FOR REPORTING HAS DOUBLED THEIR
RATE OF OF DATA COLLECTION FOR
COLLISIONS WITH LARGE ANIMALS
THAT CAN BE SALVAGED.
THIS IS TRUE IN IDAHO -- I'M NOT
SURE ISSUE IN WASHINGTON BUT
CERTAINLY IN IDAHO WHICH IS THE
LONGEST RUNNING PROGRAM.
IF I MAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALSO
OFTENTIMES LOOKED LIKE DOCTOR
SELLING MENTIONS.
YOU KNOW ON ON THE MAJOR
THOROUGHFARES ANIMALS ARE PICKED
UP PRETTY QUICKLY BY C. H. BEING
CALTRANS BOUGHT ON A LOT OF THE
ROADS AWAY FROM THE MAJOR
THOROUGHFARES I LIVE UP AND AND
ALTERADO COUNTY AND A DEAR WILL
LAY ON THE SIDE OF THE ROAD.
SOMETIMES FOR WEEK TEN DAYS AND
SIMPLY ROT.
BUT WHEN THOSE ANIMALS ARE
LAYING OUT THERE THE ATTRACT
OTHER PREDATORS WHICH OFTEN
TIMES CAN CAN RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL ACCIDENTS AND SO
FORTH.
SO GIVING THE THE GENERAL PUBLIC
THE ABILITY TO SALVAGE THE
EDIBLE PORTIONS OF WHAT HELP
CLEAN THOSE ATOMS UP SPECIALLY
IN THE AREAS THAT ARE OFTEN THE
MAJOR THOROUGHFARES.
SO THAT CAN PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS THE PUBLIC SAFETY
BECAUSE AGAIN THOSE ANIMALS OUT
OF THERE AND ELIMINATING THE
POSSIBILITY OF PRINTERS COMING
OUT AND TAKING THEM AS WELL.
YOU KNOW QUESTIONS.
STREAMING.
NOT A QUESTION I JUST A COMMENT
PLEASE -- YOU KNOW WE HAVE BEEN
VARIOUS ATTEMPTS OVER THE YEARS
I WAS JUST LOOKING AT THE
ANALYSIS -- FOR RELATED
LEGISLATION NOT NOT LEGISLATION
THAT DOES EXACTLY WHAT THIS DOES
BUT LEGISLATION THAT TRIES TO
HAVE CALTRANS TAKE THE REDUCTION
OF ANIMAL KERR COLLISIONS MORE
SERIOUSLY. TO INCENTIVIZE THE
BUILDING OF THE BOMB WILDLIFE
CORRIDORS AND THE OVERPASSES AND
GIVEN THAT THESE COLLISIONS --
CAN CERTAINLY LEAD TO HUMAN
DEATH AS WELL AS ANIMAL DOT THAT
SEEMS THAT THAT SHOULD BE.
THE FOCUS OF WHAT WE AS A
LEGISLATURE ARE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH IS MAKING SURE THAT
WE DO BILL THE OVERPASSES AND
THAT WE DO LOOK AT IT -- AT THE
DATA THAT TALKS ABOUT WHERE WE
HAVE MORE ANIMAL COLLISIONS AND
EITHER SLOW TRAFFIC DOWN OR RE
ROUTE TRAFFIC OR DO WHATEVER WE
NEED TO DO TO MAKE IT SAFER. FOR
YOU KNOW FOR PEOPLE IN CARS AND
YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD IN THE THE
ONE OH ONE IN LOS ANGELES WE'VE
HAD AT LEAST THREE MOUNTAIN
LIONS KILLED.
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
ALONE AND YET THEY'RE STILL NO
OVER PASS IN THAT AREA -- YOU
KNOW WHICH CONNECT WHICH RIGHT
NOW DIVIDES TO SORT OF PUBLIC
WILDERNESS AREAS.
SO WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THAT AND
I APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL -- I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THE HEALTH IMPACTS OF
PEOPLE WHO TRY TO TAKE THIS
WITHOUT REALLY UNDERSTANDING THE
HEALTH RISKS WITHOUT KNOWING HOW
TO PROPERLY FIELD DRESS I WORRY
ABOUT.
THE POTENTIAL DANGER OF PEOPLE
STOPPING ALONG THE ROAD -- YOU
KNOW CREATING ANOTHER AND SAFE
CONDITION SO FOR DEBT TO TODAY
I'M GOING TO BE -- JUST NOT
VOTING ON THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
RIGHT SEEN ALL THE QUESTION
DOCTOR.
YET I THINK THAT WAS ON MY
INTEND TO CLARIFY BUT THE FOR
THE READING THE ANALYSIS -- NOW
YOU'LL BE IN WE'RE ALLOW THE
MOTORIST TO RECOVER.
SO IT THAT CONCERNS ME THAT --
YOU HUMAN FATALITY IN OUR TRYING
TO REMOVE A AND AND WHATEVER OF
THE CAR MAY NOT SEE AND THE NEXT
AND FINALLY HIT THE PERSON AGAIN --
SO BECOME A VICTIM SO -- BEFORE
WE WAS SO ILLEGAL NOW WE ARE
TRYING TO MAKE IT LEGAL.
SO PURPOSE TO INTENT IS GOOD
STUFF BUT THOUGHT I WONDER WHAT
THAT THIS BILL WILL IN THE IN
DANGER.
THE HUMAN LIFE TO FLOOD SAID
THAT IT SOUNDED BUT WILL ENSURE
A AGAIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER REMEMBER
THIS IS TO NOTIFY BRING
COMMUNICATIONS TOGETHER AND SOME
OF THESE ROADWAYS THAT WERE NOT
FAMILIAR WITH BECAUSE YOU KNOW
I'M FROM LA COUNTY ORANGE COUNTY.
BUT THERE'S AREAS WHERE YOU
DON'T SEE ANOTHER PERSON FOR
THIRTY FORTY MILES AND I THINK
ANYONE WHO IS LIVES UP AND AND
THE NORTHERN PART OF CALIFORNIA
YOU CAN ACTUALLY DRIVE THIRTY
FORTY MILES.
AND NOT SEE ANYONE ELSE AND SO
THIS QUICKLY WILL BE ABLE TO TO
COMMUNICATE WITH EVERYONE SHOULD
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON AND AND I'M
SURE -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER ATHLETES
MIGHT COMMENT ON THAT AS WELL.
YES I WILL.
BE BEING ONE OF THE FEW -- ROLE
DISTRICT MEMBERS.
SAID I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
ACTUALLY BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND WOULD LOVE TO JOIN
ON AS A CO AUTHOR WITH YOU -- I
I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS OF
SOME MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ABOUT AS
FAR AS TRAINING AS FAR AS A LOT
OF THESE THINGS.
BUT IF YOU ASK ANYBODY THAT
LIVES IN A RURAL COUNTY --
WHETHER IT'S INYO COUNTY TULARE
KERN ST BERNARD YOU KNOW AND AND
ON UP -- YOU KNOW THESE THINGS
HAPPEN ALL THE TIME.
THESE THINGS CAUSE FURTHER
ACCIDENTS -- I GREW UP IN AN
AREA THAT FOUR THOUSAND FEET.
ON BACK MOUNTAIN ROADS.
THESE THINGS HAPPEN ALL THE TIME
AND EVEN THOUGH THE LEGAL PEOPLE%
TO GET OUTMOVE THE ANIMAL.
BECAUSE THEY KNEW THE NEXT GUY
GOING DOWN WOULD HIT IT.
TO AND THEN WHAT THEM TO GO OFF
A ROAD RAFEAL CLAIRE FOR INTO A
RIVER SOMETHING MUCH WORSE.
CHAU A AND IT'S ABOUT TIME WE DO.
TAKE HIS BILL FORWARD WE DO MAKE
IT LEGAL SO THAT WAY PEOPLE IN
THESE RURAL AREAS CAN DO WHAT'S
RIGHT AND MOVE THESE ANIMALS.
SO THERE'S AND FURTHER HARM DONE
TO EVERYBODY INVOLVED SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS.
HE EVEN IN IN A NON RURAL AREA I
APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTIVENESS TO
WORK ON SOMETHING.
OF THAT AFFECTS RURAL AREAS THAT
REALLY AFFECTS A LOT OF THE
FAMILY MEMBERS INVOLVED SO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND AND YOU CALL AUTHOR -- I
THINK WE'VE GOT ALL QUESTIONS
HAVE BEEN ASKED A MASK FOR A
BROKEN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS YEAH -- BUT MRS
CHAIR THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH I I
I I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU FIND
THIS BILL AS SERIOUS AS I DO.
IN THE WILD LIKE TRAFFIC SAFETY
ACT IS HERE TO GO FORWARD --
WITH YOUR SUPPORT YOUR VOTE AND
I URGENTLY AFTER THAT SUPPORT
AND THE VOTE THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NOT VOTING [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA NOT VOTING
GLORIA.
KALRA.
COLOR NOT VOTING LEVINE.
MATHIS FIVE MATHIS I BLANCA
RUBIO.
LONGER RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS I WOULD. SIX TWO ZERO WILL
KEEP THAT OPEN BROTHER MEMBERS
HAD ON THANK.
SENATE BILL -- FOR TO CENTER
[inaudible]
LARGEST [inaudible]
THE BILL.
MOTION BY MISTER MATHIS.
SECULAR MISTER SALAS.
SB FOUR OH TWO DOES HAVE A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THE MOTION AND A SECOND TO
SENATOR.
ONLY MOVE ORDER BY THE PRINCIPLE
OF MATHIS [inaudible]
SECOND MYSELF.
PLEASE GOOD MORNING A GERMAN --
GARCIA AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS HI
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE -- SP
FOUR OH TWO IS A FIVE YEAR
EXTENSION TO IN YOUR COUNTIES
ADVENTURE TRAIL PILOT PROGRAM --
IN TWENTY ELEVEN SB SIX TO WAIT
ESTABLISHES PILOT PROGRAM WHICH
ALLOWED INYO COUNTY TO DESIGNATE
SPECIFIC COUNTY ROADS AS
COMBINED USE ROUTES FOR OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE USE.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO PROGRAM
DELAYS BECAUSE OF PROTRACTED
LITIGATION THERE'S NOT BEEN
ENOUGH TIME FOR A COMPREHENSIVE
EVALUATION OF THE PILOT.
THE GOALS OF THE PROGRAM ARE TO
INCREASE TRAFFIC SAFETY IMPROVE
NATURAL RESOURCE PROTECTION
REDUCE OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
TRESPASS ON PRIVATE LAND IN
MINIMIZE IMPACTS ON COUNTY
RESIDENTS.
NEITHER THIS BILL IN NOR THE
EXISTING PILOT PROGRAM CREATE A
SINGLE NEW TRAIL OR WROTE.
IT DOES HOWEVER CREATE A BETTER
NETWORK OF TRAILS AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY A LEGAL AND
REGULATED MEANS TO ACCESS
EXISTING MAINTAINED TRAILS.
ADDITIONALLY.
BY HAVING A LINK TRAIL SYSTEM
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS THE TOOLS
PROPERLY DIRECT -- H. V. USERS
TO APPROVED ROUTES IN REDUCE THE
NEED TO POLICE ILLEGAL ACTIVITY.
THIS PROGRAM IS IMPORTANT LOCAL
ECONOMY INYO COUNTY WHICH
CONSISTS PRIMARILY OF HIGH
DESERT WITH LESS THAN 2%
PRIVATELY OWNED LAND.
HAS A ROBUST -- EACH BE
COMMUNITY AND RELIES EXTENSIVELY
ON TOURISM DOLLARS.
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
EXTENSION IN THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON AS FOUR
OH TWO AND ALONG WITH ME TODAY
ARE INYO COUNTY SHERIFF CHAPALA
WILL.
AND PAUL SMITH RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVE OF CALIFORNIA RC
RC.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS --
I AM JEFF ALL THE SHERIFF OF
INYO COUNTY OF IT HERE TO
SUPPORT AS BEFORE TO AND I'D
LIKE TO MAKE JUST A COUPLE
COMMENTS.
THE ADVENTURE TRAIL PROGRAM HAS
HAD BROAD PUBLIC SUPPORT.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HAS HAD TEN
PUBLIC HEARINGS.
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE PUBLIC
GIVE TESTIMONY INTERACT WITH THE
BOARD.
AS WELL AS A PLANNING COMMISSION
AS IT RELATES TO THE EVENTUAL
TRAILS PROGRAM.
DURING THE TIME OF THIS THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT HAS
RECEIVED NO COMPLAINTS --
RELATED TO THE ADVENTURE TRAILS
NO TRAIL PROLIFERATION.
HAS BEEN OBSERVED NO ACCIDENTS
NO LAW ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS.
IN NO INCIDENTS.
NONE OF THE PROJECTED OUTCOMES
DESCRIBED BY THE OPPONENTS OF
THE PROGRAM OF TAKEN PLACE.
IN REPORTS OF A OF VIOLATIONS ON
EACH VIS HAVE BEEN UNRELATED TO
THE INVENTION TO CHARLES PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM ALLOWS WHICH HE
USES TO USE EXISTING COUNTY
MAINTAIN ROADS TO ACCESS
CAMPGROUNDS TRAILS IN SERVICES.
TO PROTECT OUR NATURAL RESOURCES
BY EDUCATING AND ENCOURAGING
ONLY TO BE USERS TO RESPECT OR
JUST A DISTINCTIVE LANDSCAPE.
THIRTY NINE OF THE FORTY FOUR
MILES OF THE CURRENT SYSTEM ARE
ACTUALLY COUNTY MAINTAINED ROADS.
THE OTHER FIVE MILES THAT ARE IN
THIS ARE ALREADY APPROVED FOR
ONLY TO BE USE.
BY UTILIZING THE EXISTING ROADS
TROUBLE INFORMATION AND RELIGION
IS REDUCED.
WE ENCOURAGE AND EDUCATE GOING
TO BE GROUPS TO PARTICIPATE AND
STEWARDSHIP PROJECTS FOR THE
FEDERAL AND STATE AGENCIES THAT
CONTROL MUCH OF OUR UNIQUE
LANDSCAPE.
THE PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE EIGHTY PROGRAM IS SOLELY
FUNDED BY GREEN STICKER GRANT
FUNDING NO GENERAL FUNDS HAVE
BEEN USED.
WITH THE SMALL SCALE OF THIS
PROJECT ONLY SEVEN ROUTES.
WE'VE HAD LIMITED ECONOMIC
BENEFITS SO FAR BUT WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE HIM ESPECIALLY
ONE CAMPGROUND OUTSIDE THE
COMMUNITY OF BISHOP.
IN CLOSING I WOULD LIKE TO SAY A
PRIORITY FOR THIS PROJECT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN TO INFORM AND ENGAGE
THE PUBLIC.
IN THE RULES AND REGULATIONS FOR
THE USE AND ENJOYMENT OF THE
ALTERNATE SYSTEM OR EXCUSE ME
VENTURE TRAIL SYSTEM.
MORE TIME IS NEEDED BOTH EDUCATE
THE PUBLIC AND EVALUATE THE
PROGRAM.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR US
BEFORE TO TO CONTINUE THE
VENTURE TRIALS PILOT.
AND THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL SMITH
WITH RC RC RURAL COUNTIES
REACHED OUT TO SHORTFALL THE
WILLS POINT THE REASON WE'RE
HERE ASKING FOR ANOTHER
EXTENSION IS DURING THE LAST
EXTENSION -- DEBATE -- NOT ALL
OF THE TRAILS HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED DUE TO A RESOLUTIONS
WITH -- A LAWSUIT THAT OCCURRED
SEVERAL YEARS AGO ON THE
PROJECTS ARE NOW.
WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW ALL SEVEN TRAILS UP AND
RUNNING AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO THE EVALUATION WHAT
IS NEEDED HERE IS SOME EXTENSION
OF TIME SO WE URGE THE BILL.
A TO MOVE FORWARD.
WITH SPEAKS.
FOR BOTH.
THOSE WHICH IF WE CAN OPPOSITION.
IT WILL BE BACK WITH THE ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
MATHIS CENTER IS THE GRAY BILL
ON A SURE FOUL WELCOME TO
SACRAMENTO ON GLAD YOU WERE ABLE
TO MAKE THE TRIP OVER -- CAN'T
SPEAK HIGHLY ENOUGH ABOUT WHAT
YOU ALL ARE DOING WITH THE
ADVENTURE TROLLS OUT THERE IN
ALL OF THESE THINGS CENTER I'D
LIKE TO MAKE SURE WERE ADDED AS
A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR -- TODAY.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO THIS BILL
MOVING TO THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
TREATMENT I'M GONNA MAKE A
COMMENT I UNDERSTAND I THINK AND
I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO INTO CHANNEL THESE FOLKS
INTO LEGAL AREAS AND MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR YOU KNOW IN A SORT OF
A SANCTION PLACE THAT HAS BEEN
CREATED FOR THEM.
I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS AND I'D
LIKE TO BETWEEN NOW AND WHEN THE
BILL COMES BACK ON THE FLOOR TO
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT WHO THE PEOPLE ARE FOR
UTILIZING THIS AND WHETHER THIS
IS HAVING THE EFFECT.
OF GETTING THEM OUT OF PLACES
THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE I
ALSO RIDE A VEHICLE IN THE
FOREST BUT MIGHT HAS FOUR LEGS
AND FOR AND I HAVE COME ACROSS
ILLEGAL OFFROAD PEOPLE M. IN THE
ANGELES FOREST AND SEEN THE
DANGER THAT THEY CREATE WHEN
THEY'RE IN PLACES THEY'RE NOT.
SUPPOSED TO BE AND THE DAMAGE
THAT THEY CREATE IN THOSE AREAS
SO I IF THE GOAL IS TO GET THOSE
PEOPLE INTO PLACES WHERE -- WE
CAN KEEP THEM OUT OF OTHER
PLACES I I GET THAT BUT I WANT
TO UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT WHETHER YOU'RE REALLY
ACHIEVING THAT OR YOU'RE JUST
BRINGING MORE PEOPLE OUT INTO
THESE.
INTO THE WILDERNESS WHERE AND
THEY'RE JUST KIND OF GOING
EVERYWHERE SO I'M GONNA LAY OFF
THE BILL TODAY BUT HAPPY TO SIT
DOWN WITH YOU BETWEEN NOW AND
WHEN IT COMES BACK.
TO YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY GET MORE
COMFORTABLE OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS.
THE MOTION IS SECOND TO WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU I THINK IT CHAIRMAN
AND TO I APPRECIATE THAT THE
COMMENTS THAT THE SIMPLY WOMAN --
PUT FORWARD WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN
THAT FOLKS UNDERSTAND THE REAL
MOTIVATION FOR THIS IS THAT A
PILOT PROGRAM IS DESIGNED. FOR
ODD TO TO SEE IF THE IDEA WORKS
AND WITHOUT A PILOT PROGRAM
COMPLETING ITSELF SO THAT DATA
METRICS COULD BE OBTAINED.
I IT IT'S WITHOUT ITS PURPOSE SO
I THINK IDEAS MAKE CERTAIN THAT
WE LEARN FROM THIS PROGRAM.
AND FOR FOLKS WHO ARE ARE --
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT
THE THE PURPOSE OF THIS IS ALSO
TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT FOLKS ARE
NOT DEGRADING THE ENVIRONMENT
AND AS SUPPORTED THAT WE
VOLUNTEERED.
THAT MIDWAY THROUGH THIS PILOT
THAT -- WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
ANOTHER ENVIRONMENTAL UPDATE AND
REVIEW -- WE SATIN CONSULTATION
OR DISCUSSED WITH THE SIERRA
CLUB IN AND OTHER FOLKS AND THEY
WERE PLEASED WITH THAT WITH THAT
CONTRIBUTIONS SO WITH THAT
COLLEAGUES I I APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE OF
TODAY THANK YOU WE'LL ASK. FOR
ROLL CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS AT
WORK OUR SIDE.
GARCIA I GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I'D CHOI.
CHOICE I TO OUR CHIU AYE
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NOT VOTING CRISTINA
GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA.
GLORIA NOT VOTING KALRA.
COLOR NOT VOTING LEVINE.
MATHIS -- MATHIS I BLANCA RUBIO.
MARCO RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS I
WOULD [inaudible] SIX OKAY WILL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS AT ON AND BE MY HONOR TO
INCLUDE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BIGELOW
AND MATHIS AS PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHORS IS JACK THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SCOTT UNDER
DOT.
SB.
FOUR FOUR TWO SB FOUR FOUR TWO
AS A TO PASS WITH.
MANY AMENDMENTS RECOMMENDATION.
MOST BY MISTER MATHIS SEGMENTS
FRIEDMAN. TO DOT THIS CHAIRMAN
OF MEMBERS SB FOUR FOUR TWO
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS RECREATION TO PROVIDE A
LIMITED EXCEPTION. FOR CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS AND QUALIFIED
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
TO COMMERCIALIZE DISCOVERIES
EMANATING FROM CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS.
SB FOUR FOUR TWO WOULD AUTHORIZE
THE DIRECTOR THE ISSUE OF
COMMERCIALIZATION PERMIT ONLY IF
THE APPLICANT SEEKING TO PERMIT
MET CERTAIN CONDITIONS AND THE
DEPARTMENT COLLECTED APPLICATION
AND PERMIT FEES.
FEES WOULD BE DEPOSITED STATE
PARKS RECREATION FUNDS AVAILABLE
DEPARTMENT UPON APPROPRIATION
FOR THE PROTECTION CONSERVATION
RESTORATION OF PARK RESOURCES SB
FOUR FOUR TWO WILL LIKELY
GENERATE REVENUE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT FROM A REQUIRED
BENEFIT SHARING AGREEMENT.
WITH THIS CAUTIOUSLY CRAFTED
EXCEPTION WE CAN TAKE STEPS TO
PROMOTING SCIENTIFIC DISCOVERIES
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE HERE TO TESTIFY IN THE BILL
ARE JASON MURPHY AND ADRIAN
LOPEZ.
REPRESENTING THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DAVIS.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRED MEMBERS
JASON MURPHY ON BEHALF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA PLEASED TO
BE HERE TODAY AS A CO SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL STRIKES THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN --
ACADEMIC RESEARCH OPPORTUNITIES
AND NATURAL RESOURCE
PRESERVATION AND WE ASK FOR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ADRIAN LOPEZ WITH UC DAVIS THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY
JUST HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT.
THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE THANK YOU
DO THAT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
YES SIR THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE A MOTIONS SECOND BILLS
WISHES SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
HE'S GOING FORWARD.
THOSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE BRING BACK TO DIS.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS SEEN NONE.
OF THE MOTION SECOND YOU'VE
ACCEPTED IT BACK FOR THE ADMIN
RIGHT BUT WITH THE WILL LAST FOR
ROLL CALL THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA HI GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW BIGELOW I'D CHOI.
CHOICE I TO TWO I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA.
KALRA I'D LEVINE.
LEVINE I MATHIS.
MATH ASIDE BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS I
WOULD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS AS FOR MOTION.
THANK YOU FOR THAT IS BECAUSE AS
FOR WHAT.
SB FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN CABALLERO
TO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SB SEVEN SEVEN
NINE NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
TO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA GARCIA I
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU. TWO I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA.
GLORIA I'D KALRA.
I A LEVINE.
LEVINE I MATHIS -- MATHIS EYES
BLANCA RUBIO.
WALKER RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS I'D WOULD.
WE'LL BE THAT OVER THE PHONE
NUMBER SEVEN ON TWELVE ONE MORE
BILL WHAT THEY THINK THE AUTHORS
IN DROUGHT [inaudible]
THE THIS IS JUST A MATTER.
WITH THIS AMOUNTS FOR THE MOMENT.
WE'LL START AT THE TOP.
SB [inaudible]
SIXTY NINE FRIEDMAN.
HI FRIEDMAN I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA.
SB [inaudible]
SIXTY NINE HI [inaudible]
KALRA I SALAS.
SALAS NO. NINE TO THREE OF PASS
ON COLD.
OKAY.
THAT'S US -- SENATOR I'LL COME
UP WITH TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
THE BILL
.
FIVE FIVE NINE I CAN MORNING
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING AT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM HERE TO
PRESENT SB FIVE FIVE NINE ALONG
SIDE MY DEAR FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER DR
WALKING AROUND BE LEFT.
OF FIRST I STEPPED ALL OF THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND THANK
YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE.
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH ME ON
THIS BILL.
SB FIVE FIVE NINE IS A DISTRICT
BILL THAT SUPPORT IT'S FIXING
THE FRANKLIN CANAL PROJECT
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
LONG TERM SECURITY.
AND ECONOMIC VITALITY OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY.
UP ALTHOUGH THE FRANK KERN
CANALIS FEDERALLY OWNED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT LONG AGO
HANDED OFF ALL RESPONSIBILITY.
FOR THE CANAL TO LOCAL WATER
USERS WHO HAVE PAID THE FULL
COST OF CONSTRUCTION AND
MAINTENANCE OVER THE PAST
SEVENTY YEARS.
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
ABSENCE THE CANALS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
HAS AND IS CRUMBLING 60% OF THE
CANALS CAPACITY TO DELIVER WATER
HAS BEEN LOST IN THE LOWER
PORTION OF THE FACILITY -- DUE
TO LAND SUBSIDENCE AS A RESULT
OF THE RECENT HISTORIC DROUGHT.
THE CANAL IS VITAL FOR
DELIVERING WATER. TO RECHARGE
GROUNDWATER AQUIFER'S RELIED ON
BY COMMUNITIES IN MY DISTRICT
AND BEYOND ESPECIALLY ON THE
VALLEY'S EAST SIDE LIKE ORANGE
COVE LINDSEY FRESNO AND OTHERS.
EMITATIONSON CANAL DELIVERIES
WILL FURTHER CHALLENGE THE
VALLEY'S ABILITY TO MEET THE
STATE IT'S SUSTAINABLE GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT ACT GOALS.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR SB FIVE FIVE
NINE IS AN EFFORT TO HELP MY
DISTRICT MEET THESE GOALS.
TODAY WITH ME I HERE'S ALSO TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS
ALEX BEARING REPRESENTING
DIFFERENT WATER AUTHORITY.
AND DIVINE MOHAR REPRESENT ARVIN
EDISON WATER STORAGE DISTRICT.
AND I'LL GO AHEAD AND HANDED
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE.
THANK YOU AND WHAT AN HONOR IT
IS TO HAVE A SENATOR WHO I CAN
WORK WITH AND PARTNER WITH ON
THINGS AS IMPORTANT AS WATER TO
OUR COMMUNITIES -- I JUST WOULD
LIKE TO IF I CAN MISTER CHAIR
SAVE MY COMMENTS AS A REBUTTAL
FOR ANY OPPOSITION THAT WE FACE
AND ALLOW -- THOSE HERE IN
SUPPORT TO TAKE MY TIME.
THE MOTION AND A SECOND PLEASE --
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK BRIEFLY.
LIKE SENATOR HER DAUGHTER SAID
MY NAME IS ALEXANDER BEARING I
WORK FOR FRONT WATER AUTHORITY
WE OPERATE MAINTAIN FRANK KERN
CAL WE'RE ALSO THE BILL
SPONSORED.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THE
CAT THE CANALS BURTON FROM MORE
THAN JUST AGRICULTURE.
IT'S PART OF A STATEWIDE WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE AND DELIVERY
SYSTEM AND ONE OF THE AUTHORIZED
PURPOSES FOR THE CANAL IS STILL
OF DELIVER NOT JUST IRRIGATION
AND MUNICIPAL SUPPLIES BUT ALSO
WATER FOR GROUND WATER RECHARGE.
IN MOST YEARS MORE THAN HALF THE
WATER THE CANAL DELIVERS A
SPECIFICALLY USED TO RECHARGE
GROUNDWATER AND NOT THE WATER
THAT'S BEEN BEING UNABLE TO BE
DELIVERED BECAUSE OF THIS
SUBSIDENCE PROBLEM UP TO THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE FEET PER
YEAR.
WHICH IS MORE THAN HALF THE SIZE
OF MILLERTON LAKE FOR EXAMPLE.
YOU'LL LIKELY HEAR TODAY THAT
THE STATE SHOULD INVEST IN THIS
PROJECT BECAUSE IT'S A FEDERAL
RESPONSIBILITY IT'S ACTUALLY A
LOCAL RESPONSIBILITY.
LIKE SENATOR HER DAUGHTER SAID
WE'VE BEEN OPERATING MAINTAIN
THE CANAL FOR MANY YEARS WE PAY
THE FULL COST OF THE CANAL SINCE
NINETEEN FORTY NINE ALMOST ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN TOTAL.
IN CONSTRUCTION MAINTENANCE AND
WE'VE BEEN FULLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE CANAL UNDER CONTRACT WITH
RECLAMATION SINCE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HOLDS TITLE TO THE
CANAL LIKE THE PINK SLIP -- BUT
WE PAID OFF MORE WORKING
AGGRESSIVELY TOWARDS OBTAINING
TITLE FOR THE FACILITY SO WILL
BE FULLY LOCALLY OWNED AND
CONTROLLED.
YOU MAY ALSO HEAR THAT THE CANAL
DOESN'T BENEFIT BENEFIT ANYONE
BUT FARMERS.
THAT'S NOT TRUE EITHER MOST OF
THE EAST SIDE COMMUNITIES AND
HOUSEHOLDS RELY ON THE SAME
GROUND WATER AQUIFER'S.
FURTHER SUPPLY THAT THE CANAL
WAS BUILT TO HELP MORE THAN
SEVENTY YEARS AGO.
THEY'RE ALSO AFFECTED BY THIS
PROBLEM AND WOULD BE HELPED BY
THE SOLUTION.
AS AN EXAMPLE TULAREID IS ONE
OF THE THE CANAL USERS.
THEY NOTICED THAT SOME OF THE
GROUND WATER QUALITY IN THE
NEARBY COMMUNITY FOLKY FEEL WAS
MUCH BETTER NEAR THE GROUND
WATER RECHARGE BASIN.
AND SO THEY PARTNERED WITH SELF
HELP ENTERPRISES TO PURCHASE
SOME LAND ON THE NORTH SIDE OF
OKEY BILL TO ESTABLISH A NEW
GROUND WATER RECHARGE BASE AND
TO HOPEFULLY ACHIEVE THE SAME
BENEFITS THAT THEY'VE SEEN
ELSEWHERE.
THOSE ARE THE SORTS OF PROJECTS
THAT ARE POSSIBLE RIGHT NOW BUT
WILL BE LESS POSSIBLE UNLESS
THIS PROBLEM IS ADDRESSED.
FINALLY SOME CRITICS SAY THAT IS
THE STATE SHOULDN'T OR CAN'T OR
DOESN'T INVEST IN FEDERAL
PROJECTS.
IN FACT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAS INVESTED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN FEDERALLY CONSTRUCTED LOCALLY
MAINTAIN FACILITIES FLOOD
CONTROL PROJECTS ARE PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF THE SORT OF
INVESTMENT IN OUR STATE WORD
STATEWIDE NETWORK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE.
JUST LIKE THE FRANKLIN CANALIS
WITH OUR WATER CONVEYANCE
SYSTEMS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF STATE
INVESTMENTS AND LOCAL FACILITIES
IS THE OWNER ALL AMERICAN CANAL
LINING.
THE COMMITTEE SHOULD KNOW THAT
WE'VE ALWAYS USED THIS AS A
POTENTIAL LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL PARTNERSHIP.
LOCAL AGENCIES IN CANAL USERS
ARE COMMITTED TO PAYING A SHARE
OF THIS PROJECT AND ARE VALLEY
DELEGATION CONGRESS AND SENATOR
DIANNE FEINSTEIN OF COMMITTED TO
SEEK APPROPRIATIONS FOR FELL
INVESTMENT AS WELL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
IF THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM I DIDN'T
GET INTO THE TECHNICAL DETAILS
OR ANYTHING ELSE LIKE THAT SO
THANK YOU TO BE HER THANK YOU.
THE QUICKNESS THANK CHAIRMAN
OTHER MEMBERS -- AGAIN MY NAME
IS JIM MORE HARM WITH THE THE
ARVIN EDISON WATER STORAGE
DISTRICT -- WHERE THE LAST
CONTRACTOR ON THE FRANKLIN CANAL
AND WE ARE BY FAR THE MOST
IMPACTED DISTRICT -- OF THE
FRANKLIN COME OUT FROM THE LOSS
OF CAPACITY -- FROM AN
OPERATIONAL PERSPECTIVE -- THE
IMPORTATION OF FRANK -- CANAL
WATER INTO THE SOUTHEAST PORTION
OF KERN COUNTY -- HAS STABILIZE
WATER LEVELS REALLY FOR THE LAST
FIFTY YEARS SINCE WE'VE BEEN IN
OPERATION -- AND IN LARGE PART
DUE TO THE GROUNDWATER RECHARGE
ACTIVITIES THAT WE UNDERTAKE --
THESE RECHARGE ACTIVITIES HAVE
PROVIDED A TREMENDOUS WATER
QUALITY BENEFIT TO SEVERELY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN OUR
AREA -- YOU KNOW SOME OF THOSE
LAMONT ARVIN THAT WE'D PATCH --
WHICH WAS DETAILED IN THE THE
PULITZER PRIZE BUT GRAPES OF
WRATH HE HAS WILL REMEMBER THAT --
THESE SEVERELY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES -- RELY ON DRINKING
WATER THROUGH GROUND WATER.
IN WHICH OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW WE
WE RECHARGE -- IN FACT -- ROBERT
RAZA WITH THE ORGAN COMMITTEE
SERVICES DISTRICT -- HAS
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT HE THEY SEE
IMPROVE WATER QUALITY CONDITIONS
IN THEIR SERVICE AREA WHEN WE
ARE RECHARGING IN ARVIN EDISON --
YOU KNOW HAVING THE PREDICTABLE
SUPPLY OF WATER SUPPLY -- IT IS
ONLY POSSIBLE WITH A FRANKLIN
CANAL FIX -- WE'VE GOT TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO RECHARGE
THE WE CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
THESE BENEFITS GOING FORWARD --
YOU KNOW FRANK -- CANAL IT IS IS
DEGRADED NEARLY FIFTY MILES
UPSTREAM OF ARVIN EDISON -- IT
IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT -- NOT
OUR OPERATIONS YOU KNOW NOT
FRONT WATER AUTHORITIES THE
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE --
NOR THOSE THAT ARE SERVED BY THE
FRANKLIN CANAL BECAUSE THESE
PROBLEMS -- AND NONE THE LESS WE
GOT TO FIX THE PROBLEM -- YOU
KNOW THE FRANK -- CANAL IS A
STATE WIDE.
IMPORTANT -- FACILITY -- IT'S
NOT A REGIONAL OR LOCAL -- ONLY
FACILITY -- WITHOUT THE FIX --
PROVIDED THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE ENOUGH WATER TO RECHARGE
BECAUSE WE CAN GET PAST THE THE
SUBSIDENCE OWN PLUS WITH THE
INCREASED EXTRACTIONS -- BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE THE WATER TO GET
EXTRACTED -- YOU KNOW THE THE
GROUND WATER OCT FOR WILL
DECLINE.
AND OBVIOUSLY WITH CIGNA AND
IT'S GOING TO BE -- A PROBLEM
AND AND SO YOU KNOW SIGNAL
COMPLIANCE -- IN OUR IN OUR
MANAGEMENT AREA WILL SUFFER
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS INCLUDING
SUBSIDENCE -- IN RECHARGE
ACTIVITIES CAN BE MITIGATED --
FOR SUBSIDENCE CONCERNS AND
FRANKLIN COULD NOT FIX IS IS IS
PARAMOUNT TO OUR SUCCESS.
AND CONTINUED BENEFIT TO THE
SEVERELY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
FRANKLIN CANAL IS REALLY THE
ONLY -- ARTERY ON THE SIDE OF
THE VALLEY.
SO.
WITH THAT I THINK IF YOU GET
YOUR TIME AND THANK YOU WE HAVE
A HAS TO FOLKS WHO WANT TO SIGN
ON IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL
SHOT YOUR AND TWENTY HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTIES OF FRESNO
KERN AND TULARE IN SUPPORT AS
FOR AYE BOTH THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MERION
WARMER DAM ON BEHALF OF RURAL
COUNTIES WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
MEASURES TWO QUICK POINTS.
THIS IS A KEY.
COMPONENT OF MEETING ARE SAFE
DRINKING WATER CRITERION THE
COMMUNITIES BEING SERVED AS WELL
AS SIGMA IMPLEMENTATION WE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
GAIL DEL HAVE WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU.
JULIE HALL WITH THE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES HERE
IN SUPPORT.
DOCTOR REVEREND MINISTER CIVIL
RIGHTS AND HUMAN RIGHTS WE NEED
CLEAN DRINKING WATER CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING THIS
BILL.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
THE KELP THE SOUTH VALLEY WATER
ALLIANCE CALIFORNIA CITRUS
MUTUAL IN CALIFORNIA FOR FREE
ASSOCIATION OF SPORT.
DANNY.
DANNY MARKLEY CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION SUPPORT. ONE
OF THE MEAT ON A WITHOUT ABOUT
CALIFORNIA.
I'M A TO WEAR TWEENER ON THIS --
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE AMENDMENTS
WE THINK THE AMENDMENTS STRIKE A
GOOD PATH FORWARD HOWEVER I
THINK THAT -- AND WE WOULD HAVE
TO SEE THE FULL A BILL IN PRINT
IN ORDER FOR US TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION WHERE WE GET A LOT.
BUT I THINK WHAT WE WANT TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND IN THE
SPONSORS TO GET TO THAT PLACE
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING PUBLIC GUARDS WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND LIKE
OUR MY COLLEAGUE FROM OUT OF ON
ALSO.
A TWEENER I THINK WE'RE LIKELY
TO SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION
AT THIS POINT -- IT WE RECOGNIZE
THE NEED FOR STATE INVESTMENT
AND REPAIRING THIS FACILITY FOR
A LOT OF THE REASONS ALREADY
ARTICULATED -- CIGNA IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IN RETURN THE ABILITY
RECHARGE IS REALLY IMPORTANT --
WE WE THINK THE CURRENT FORM THE
BILL DOESN'T HAVE.
IS TO IS TO WIDE OPEN I THINK
THAT THE OF THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED IN THE COMMITTEE.
ANALYSIS ARE ON POINT SIX AND
PUT SOME STRINGS AND STATE
OVERSIGHT OF REALLY IMPORTANT
AND WE'RE GONNA MAKE THIS LARGE
OF AN INVESTMENT NECESSARILY BUT
LOOK FOR THE CONTINUING THE
DISCUSSION AND SEEING HOW THOSE
AMENDMENTS.
CHECK OUT TO HOPEFULLY GET TO A
FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THE MORNING BROWN AND ASSOCIATES
OF CALIFORNIA -- ADMITTEDLY WE
ARE STILL REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS OF THE COMMUTE OF
GAVE HOWEVER WE DO WANT TO
PREACH WE DO APPRECIATE THE
PUBLIC PROCESS THESE.
AMENDMENTS THAT THE COMMITTEE --
OFFERED UP A WE DO STILL HAVE
SOME COMMITTEE -- SOME CONCERNS
WITH THE AMENDMENT SOWE'D BE
HAPPY TO TALK TO THE AUTHOR
ABOUT HOWEVER -- WE WILL REMAIN
IN OPPOSITION RIGHT NOW I JUST
DON'T WANT TO GIVE FULL REASONS
WHY BECAUSE WE STILL ARE
REVIEWING THE MOMENTS -- SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ENTER STUFF ON THE BILL
THANK YOU FORTY IN FROM.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OF FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISS LIVING.
YEAH I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHOR -- FOR THE
WORK ON THIS -- HEARD A LOT OF
CONCERNS FROM PEOPLE IN IN
TESTIMONY I THINK THERE.
IT'S GOOD I MEAN THIS IS A
REALLY THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS
BETTER THAN ANYONE ELSE HOW HARD
WATER ISSUES CAN BE.
FOR US TO PURSUE IN THE
LEGISLATURE OF COURSE THE
SPECIAL INTERESTS THE
STAKEHOLDERS SHOW WITH THIS
EVERY DAY AND SO WE TRY.
TO BALANCE THOSE INTERESTS OUT
SO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF I
THINK THAT HAS SOME INSIGHTFUL
POINTS AS WE'VE HEARD -- ALSO --
I JUST WANTED TO SAY THANKS TO
THE SIERRA CLUB REPRESENTATIVE
FOR NOT WANT TO TALK ABOUT
ISSUES THAT THEY HADN'T FULLY
DONE -- LOOKED AT BEFORE I WAS
REALLY THAT WAS GOOD SPOT BUT I
THINK THAT YOUKNOW.
THAT THE FACT THAT -- BROADER
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT THERE IS
WORK BEING DONE ON THE BILL AS
WE SPEAK IS AN IMPORTANT POINT
TO THAT -- THAT WAS MADE IN ALL
OF THAT SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THIS TODAY AND AGAIN THANK YOU
THIS VERY DIFFICULT WORK FOR
PART OF THE STATE THAT WE'VE
BEEN STRUGGLING ON THESE WATER
ISSUES FOR A VERY LONG TIME SO
I'M GRATEFUL TO SEE US.
COMING TO THE POINT THAT WERE AT
SALAS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE
TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR AS WELL IN
THE STEAM THAT PRINCE BECAUSE
AUTHORS.
LISTED ON THE BILL AS WELL BUT
YOU KNOW THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM
ESPECIALLY NOT JUST FOR THE
VALLEY BUT REALLY FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE TALK ABOUT
TRYING TO GET CLEAN DRINKING
WATER TO COMMUNITIES THAT.
ARE REALLY SUFFERING.
WE GOT A FIX CALIFORNIA'S PIPES
SB FIVE FIVE NINE HELPS FIX
CALIFORNIA'S PIPES.
RIGHT WE KNOW WE'RE LOSING
MILLIONS OF ACRES OF WATER EVERY
SINGLE YEAR BECAUSE OF
SUBSIDENCE THE SUBSIDENCE ON ON
THE FRANK CANAL IS SIGNIFICANT
AND WE ALSO HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA AQUEDUCT AS WELL.
FOR TALKING ABOUT REALLY TRYING
TO MEET OUR CALIFORNIA GOALS.
OF SIGMA FOR TALKING ABOUT
TRYING TO MEET SAFE DRINKING
WATER GOALS SB FIVE FIVE NINE AS
PART OF THE SOLUTION I JUST WANT
TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR HER
WORK ON THIS.
ISSUE AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
MEASURE HERE TODAY AS WELL AS
FRIEDMAN FALL BUT MISTER MATHIS.
THANK YOU -- I DON'T KNOW THIS
AREA VERY WELL SO -- I'M JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE PROJECT
A LITTLE MORE SO YOU'VE BEEN
TALKING A LOT ABOUT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
NOT HAVING SAFE DRINKING WATER
WHICH I I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND IS
A HUGE CONCERN IN A PROBLEM IN
THE AREA.
BUT I'M TRYING TO RECONCILE THAT
WITH THE STAFF ANALYSIS OF THE
BILL A WHICH I'M JUST GOING TO
READ FROM THAT AND MAYBE YOU CAN
RESPOND AND I HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION IT SAYS THE FRANKLIN
CANAL IS USED ALMOST ENTIRELY.
BY TWENTY AGRICULTURAL WATER
AGENCIES WHICH COLLECTIVELY --
GATE EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE THOUSAND ACRES OF FARMLAND --
AND THEN IT GOES ON TO SAY THAT
IT'S THOSE SUBJECTS AND THE FIRE
WATER AUTHORITY THAT SHOULD
SHARE THE COST OF REPAIRING THE
CANAL NOT THE STATE REPAIRS.
SO YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
THEIR DRINKING WATER BUT THE
ANALYSIS IS PAINTING A PICTURE
OF A CANAL THAT'S BEING USE COME
COMPLETELY BY AGRICULTURAL --
CONCERNS NOT BY.
YOU KNOW MAYBE THOSE ARE
DOWNSTREAM USERS.
BUT IF THAT'S THE CASE WHY ARE
WE TALKING WHY ARE WE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THOE AGRICULTURAL
USE WHERE WE TALKING KEEP
TALKING ABOUT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHEN THEY'RE
NOT USING THE CANAL ACCORDING TO
THE ANALYSIS.
AND THEN SECONDLY WHY SHOULDN'T
THOSE AGRICULTURAL USERS BE
PAYING FOR THE PROJECT.
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHICH
OWNS THE PROJECT SO WHY ARE WE
LETTING THE GOT FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OFF THE HOOK WHEN
THEY SHOULD BE PAYING FOR THIS
THERE THE OWNER OF IT.
WHY ARE WE DIPPING INTO THE
GENERAL FUND FOR THE REST OF THE
REPAIRS TO PAY FOR AN
AGRICULTURAL WATER PROJECT?
IF I MAY I'D ACTUALLY REALLY
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION BUT I'M
NOT SURE THAT WE WROTE THE
ANALYSIS AND WHILE I TRULY DO
RESPECT -- THE COMMITTEE'S WORK
ON THIS BILL I WOULD HAVE
DISAGREED AND SAID THAT IT'S
BOTH THAT WE BOTH HAVE FARM LAND
AND FARM WORKERS WHO.
ARE IMPACTED BY WHAT HAPPENS ON
THE FRONT KERN CANAL AS
TESTIFIED.
BY THOSE IN OUR BEEN EDISON BUT
IS NOW THEY'RE GETTING THEIR
WATER FROM THE CANAL SO WHAT
HAPPENS IS THERE'S A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILE CANAL TO GET FROM
MILLER TEN LAKE DOWN TO
BAKERSFIELD WHERE OUR COLLEAGUE
IN THE SOUTH IS FROM.
AND ROUGHLY ABOUT AT ABOUT MILE
MARKER ONE HUNDRED THERE
SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH SUBSIDENCE
THAT IT'S DECREASING CAPACITY
DUE.
TO THE COUNTY ROADS THAT ARE
OVER LYING AT NOT ALLOWING IT TO
BE FILLED FULLY NOW I WOULD LOVE
TO INVITE YOU DOWN AND SHOW YOU
AT FIRST HAND BECAUSE WHAT
OCCURS IS BY THE DECREASE IN
CAPACITY IT LEADS TO US NOT
BEING ABLE TO HAVE
SUSTAINABILITY.
IF I CAN'T GET THE WATER TURNED
TO WHERE WE'RE DOING RECHARGE.
I CAN'T HAVE LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY IN THE VALLEY BUT
AND THAT'S IT THIS IS THE
PROJECT GOING TO NOW BRING CLEAN
WATER TO THE PEOPLE THAT YOU
KEEP MENTIONING BECAUSE IT'S
READS AS THOUGH THIS IS GOING TO
FARMS NO THIS IS
YET AND WE TALKED ABOUT ORANGE
COVE AND THE MAYOR OF ORANGE
COVE IS WHICH IS ON THE EAST
SIDE IS.
MAYOR VICTOR LOPEZ DAME RELY
UPON THE WATER FROM THE FRONT
KERN CANAL FOR THEIR CLEAN
DRINKING WATER.
WITHOUT THAT ABILITY OF HAVING
THE FRONT KERN CANAL IN THAT
CAPACITY WE'RE GOING TO AFFECT
AREAS.
LIKE EAST PORTER FELL AND OTHER
AREAS IN THE VALLEY AND SO I'M --
I'LL PROBABLY TO STOP SERAPHINA
MIGHT FOR THEN I WOULD ASK --
STAFF TO RESPOND TO THAT BECAUSE
IF YOU'RE SAYING THAT THEIR
ANALYSIS IS AND CRACKED I'D LIKE
TO COME HERE THEIR RESPONSE TO
THAT.
OKAY AND THEN AND THEN I WILL
ALSO -- ASKED IF I MAY MISTER
CHAIR MAYBE COULD ANSWER SOME A
MISREAD BINS CONCERNS IT'S LOW
LET'S FINISH YOUR QUESTIONS AND
THEN I'LL ALLOW EITHER THE
WITNESSES ARE YOURSELF AND THEN
AND I'M GONNA READ AGAIN FROM
THE ANALYSIS BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
I HAVE YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW TO
BASE MY DECISION.
ON IT SAYS THE FRONT WATER
AUTHORITY HAS A CONTRACT WITH
THE U. S. BUREAU OF RECLAMATION
TO MAINTAIN THE CANAL INCLUDING
HEAVY MAINTENANCE OF THE KIND
NEEDED.
CURRENT PULMONARY ESTIMATES FOR
THE FULL RESTORATION OF THE
CANNELLA ROUGHLY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WITH THE FRYING
DIVISION OF THE CV P. AMOUNTS
FOR MORE THAN A MILLION ACRES
THAT'S TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
ACRE.
THIS IS NOT A HEAVY BURDEN I
WOULD ACTUALLY BE A LIGHT BURDEN
FOR REGION GROWING HIGH VALUE
ORCHARDS AND OTHER CROPS IT IS
MORE THAN REASONABLE TO REQUEST
THAT YOU SB ARE IN FRONT WORK
TOGETHER TO RESTORE THE FRANK
KERN CANAL.
ANY DELAY.
OR AVOIDANCE UNDERTAKING THE
RIGHT.
THE RECONSTRUCTION OF THE CANAL
UNTIL SOMEONE ELSE PICKS UP THE
TAB MILLION MERELY ILLUSTRATES
THAT IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE TENDED TO WITH
URGENCY NOW THAT THEY'RE SAYING
THAT THE ARGUMENT IN OPPOSITION --
I THINK STAFF IS JUST.
I DON'T IN THAT THEY'RE ARGUING
THAT THEY'RE SAYING THAT'S WHAT
PEOPLE HAVE ARGUED AGAINST IT
THAT'S GREAT SO I AM CONCERNED
THAT WERE NOW USING TAXPAYER
MONEY. TO BAIL OUT THESE VERY
LARGE AGRICULTURAL AND I LOVE I
LOVE CROPS AND I LOVE FARMS BUT
IF THEY'RE GROWING HIGH VALUE
CROPS AND ARE CAPABLE OF DOING
THIS FOR TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
ACRE -- WHY DO WE THEN HAVE TO
TAKE MONEY FROM THE TAXPAYERS
WHO COULD BE INVESTING IN AREAS
WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HAVE YOU KNOW LARGE
INDUSTRY COME IN AND HELP THEM
AND IF IF I MAY AND?
CANNOT KEEP PACE THROUGH YOU
MISTER CHAIR -- I THINK THERE
NEEDS TO BE COLLABORATION AND
FOR US TO FIX THIS PROBLEM WE
CAN'T KEEP KICKING THIS CAN DOWN
THE ROAD AND FOR TOO MANY YEARS
WE HAVE SPENT.
MONEY LOCALLY UP TO A BILLION
DOLLARS TO HELP TO REPAIR IT.
THERE LOCAL LEGISLATORS ARE NOW
ASKING FOR SOME STATE SUPPORT AS
WELL BECAUSE OF THE CRISIS THAT
WE'RE CURRENTLY AND SO THE
AGRICULTURAL THOSE FARMS AND FRY
AND IT'S ALL FOR THEY ALSO
KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD OR
THE INVESTING.
I'M HAPPY TO STEP IN HERE AND
ADD A COUPLE DATA POINTS -- SO I
JUST WANTED TO RESPOND TO ONE
THING THAT YOU SAID EARLIER
MISTER YOU'RE NOT MISS FRIEDMAN
ABOUT -- YOUR QUESTION ON WHO IS
REALLY BENEFITING AND DOES THIS
ACTUALLY HELP -- COMMUNITIES
THERE AND HOW THEY RELATE AND
GROUND WATER.
THE ONE OF THE GREATEST
TRAGEDIES OF THIS PROBLEM RIGHT
NOW IS THAT.
THE WATER THAT CAN'T BE
DELIVERED IS ENTIRELY TO BE USED
FOR RECHARGE SO.
ALL OF THOSE COMMUNITIES FOR
RELYING ON GROUNDWATER AQUIFER'S
THAT THIS CANNELLA SUSTAIN FOR
SEVENTY YEARS.
ARE GOING TO BE IMPACTED BECAUSE
THAT'S THE WATER THEY CAN'T BE
DELIVERED SO THERE'S STILL SOME
WATER IS BEING DELIVERED FOR AG
USERS.
BUT THE WATER THAT THEY WOULD
GENERALLY TAKE WHEN IT'S A
REALLY HIGH FLOW CONDITION AND
JUST SINK DOWN TO THE GROUND
THEY CAN'T TAKE.
AND SO THAT THAT'S THE IMPACT
THAT COMES TO THAT BROADER
COMMUNITY BEYOND JUST THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE TAKING SERVICE WATER
AND USING IT FOR MUNICIPAL
SUPPLIES OR FOR FARM FARMS BY SO.
THAT THAT IS ONE YOU KNOW. ONE
PART OF THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION YOUR SECOND QUESTION
ABOUT -- YOU KNOW WHO WHO SHOULD
BE PAYING HOW MUCH SHOULD THEY
BE PAYING.
THE ALISON ANALYSIS IN HERE
POINTS TO TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR FIX.
RIGHT NOW THE THE PROJECT THAT
WE HAVE FINALIZED THE DESIGN ON
IS THREE HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT'S BIGGER THAN TWO ONE
MILLION DOLLARS BY A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT WE ARE PUTTING IN MONEY
WE ARE HOPE WE ARE ACTIVELY.
LOBBYING THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WHO IS WORKING REALLY HARD TO
TRY AND GET AN APPROPRIATION AS
WELL FOR THIS PROBLEM I WILL
ALSO.
I ALSO JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT FRONT WATER THIRTY HAS
LOOKED AT OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
WITH LIKE LOW COST FINANCING
FEDERAL LOANS AND WE APPLIED FOR
WITH YOU ALONE LAST YEAR BUT
GUESS WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T LOAN MONEY.
TO FIX ITS OWN FACILITIES SO IT
DOESN'T LOAN MONEY TO ITSELF SO
THAT WAS SOMETHING WE WERE
ELIGIBLE -- FOR WE'VE LOOKED AT
PRIVATE BONDING AS WELL --
BECAUSE WE DON'T ON THE FACILITY
THE THE INTEREST RATES ARE
EXORBITANT THERE NOTHING THAT
THIS COMMUNITY COULD AFFORD.
SO WE'RE RIGHT WE'RE NOT TRYING
TO LOOK FOR ANYONE TO BAIL US
OUT WE'RE LOOKING FOR PEOPLE
THAT CAN BE PARTNERS AN ENTITIES
THAT CAN BE PARTNERS SO JUST TO
BE CLEAR SO I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND I'M JUST READING FROM
THE ANALYSIS THESE ARE NOT MY
ARGUMENTS I KNOW.
I KNOW THAT'S MY RESPONSE YET
WHAT THE STAFF WROTE -- SO THIS
IS A FEDERALLY OWNED FACILITY
AND YOU'RE ASKING THIS THE
TAXPAYERS OF CALIFORNIA TO PAY
TO FIX A FEDERAL -- PROJECT.
WE'RE ASKING THEM.
RESTING TO TO BE PARTNERS WITH
LOCALS FOR AND LIKE I SAID
BEFORE WE ARE PURSUING TITLE THE
TEAM TITLE FOR THE FACILITY BUT
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A FEW YEARS
SO.
IT WILL BE A LOCAL FACILITY
EVENTUALLY AND RIGHT NOW IT IS
ENTIRELY LOCALLY FUNDED SO.
WE ARE ASKING FOR FOR THE STATE
TO HELP. TO HELP TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS OPPORTUNITY THAT IS
THERE TO HELP THE VALLEYMEET
SOME OF ITS CRITICAL GOALS THAT
ARE REALLY HARD TO MEET FOR IT
IN THE NEXT TEN TO TWENTY YEARS
WE HAVE ON SIGMA ON DRINKING
WATER.
THANK YOU SO I I'M I'M DONE I
JUST YOU KNOW I WHEN I READ.
SOMETHING LIKE THIS AN ANALYSIS
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
GET THE RESPONSE AND THAT'S WHY
I'M ASKING THESE QUESTIONS I
HAVE NOT BEEN TO THE AREA.
I'M FAIRLY AGNOSTIC MY WITH MY
DAUGHTER STAND WHAT THE
RESPONSES TO SERIOUS CONCERNS
BROUGHT UP IN ALICE'S SPECIAL
WILL TAKE AND WE HAVE A SALAS
FALL BUT MISTER.
MATHIS YEAH.
YES I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY ONE
THING THAT PART OF THE ANNOUNCES
THE MISTREATMENT OF READING
ABOUT WAS FROM THE OPPOSITION
WAS FROM OUR LETTER THAT ARE
SUPPLIED -- AND SO TO KIND OF
RESPECT AND IF I MAY RESPOND TO
SOME OF THOSE POINTS JUST TO
CLARIFY WHAT WE ARE ARGUING IN
THE LETTER -- THE LET IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT FIVE OF THE
THIRTY THREE ENTITIES THAT
CURRENTLY USE THE CANAL OUR USER
FROM MUNICIPAL AND INDUSTRIAL
USES.
I THINK THAT FRESNO -- CITY COVE
WARNS US OUR OWN ORANGE COVE
LINDSEY FRY AND MADERA COUNTY OF
THOSE FIVE THOSE ARE THE ONLY
THAT USE THE OF THOSE ARE THE
ONLY ENTITIES THAT USE A FOUR
YEAR AND I MEAN START FOR
AGRICULTURE MUNICIPAL IN.
LIKE USES ALL THE OTHER THIRTY
THREE ALL THE OTHER TWENTY EIGHT
USE THOSE.
USE THE WATER IN THE CANAL FOR
AGRICULTURE USES OUR ARGUMENT IS
THAT IF YOU ARE ARGUING THAT
THIS SHOULD BE USED FOR SAVING
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
DID YOU NEED TO PUT YOUR MARK
FIVE THOSE FIVE SPECIFICALLY FOR
THIS.
PROJECT BASICALLY THE OTHER
TWENTY EIGHT PROJECTS THAT ARE
USING FOR AGRICULTURE OR NOT
AGAINST AGRICULTURE ANYTHING
THOSE THAT NEED TO COME FROM
ANOTHER SUBSET OF FUNDS NOT
NECESSARILY FROM THE FUND THAT
YOU'RE ASKING THE RATE PAYERS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO USE THAT.
THAT I JUST WANNA CLARIFY THAT'S
THE ARGUMENT THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO MAKE AND AGAIN WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE ARE WE WANT TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR TO KIND OF
CLARIFY THAT ISSUE.
SALAS THANK YOU AND I JUST
WANTED TO PROVIDE PROBABLY A
LITTLE MORE CONTEXT FOR MISS
FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS AS YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WE KEEP HEARING
THE CITIES OF ORANGE COVE
LINDSEY SOME OF THOSE THAT ARE
ALONG THE EAST SIERRA -- RANGE
AND THE THING IS IS ALL OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES RELY ON SURFACE
WATER.
BECAUSE OF THE GRANITE IN THE
GEOGRAPHY OF THE AREA THEY CAN'T
WATER BANK LIKE OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE.
RIGHT THERE'S REGIONAL WATER
BREAKS UP AND DOWN THE ENTIRE
STATE THEY CAN'T DO THAT THERE'S
COMPLETELY RELIANT ON THAT
SURFACE WATER.
AND BECAUSE OF LOSING SO MUCH
WATER IN THE SUBSIDENCE.
THEIR ABILITY TO GET THAT
SURFACE WATER TO EITHER BLANDER
CREATE SAFER DRINKING WATER
STANDARDS IS SEVERELY HAMPERED
AND THAT'S WHY.
YOU KNOW SB FIVE FIVE NINE IS
ACTUALLY TRYING TO AIM AT THAT.
FOR THE FIRST PART THE SECOND
PART OF THE THE QUESTION TERMS
OF LIKE.
WHO'S PAYING THE FEES THE THING
IS IS YOU CAN'T FIX THE WATER
PIPE WITHOUT EVERYBODY
BENEFITING.
SO RATHER THAN WELL I MEAN I
WOULD JUST -- EMPLOYER TO EACH
OF MY COLLEAGUES AS LIKE LET'S
LEAVE NO CALIFORNIAN BEHIND.
LET'S LEAVE NO CALIFORNIAN
BEHIND AND ACTUALLY HAVE THEM
HAVE SAFE DRINKING WATER NO
MATTER WHAT PART OF THE STATE
THAT THEIR FRIENDS ESPECIALLY
WHEN THEY'RE RELIANT ON THE
SURFACE DRINKING WATER -- YOU
KNOW AND YOU KNOW HISTORICALLY
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE FOR THE
FRANK KERN CANAL WHO ACTUALLY
PAY FOR IT WASN'T INVESTMENT
FROM ALL PARTIES THE AG USERS
ACTUALLY PAID -- HEAVILY
INITIALLY INTO IT -- THEY'RE NOT
GOING AND UNTAPPED TO ACTUALLY
PAY FOR THIS PROJECT AS WELL IF
YOU LOOK AT THE SUPPORT LETTERS
YOU KNOW FROM CONGRESS TO WORK
WITH.
THAT SENATORS DONE WITH SENATOR
FEINSTEIN AND SOME OF THE OTHER
UP HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES IT'S
ACTUALLY TRYING TO LIKE WE ALL
DO RIGHT WORLD TRYING.
TO GET BUNDLES OF MONEY TO PUT
IT ALL TOGETHER TO CREATE A
GREATER GOOD.
INSIDE I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
THAT COMMENT THANK YOU MISTER
MINISTER MATH OF ALL THE ADVICE
HE HIRED.
I'D LIKE.
TO THING MISTER SALAS FOR HIS
COMMENTS ON YOU KNOW FOR BETTER
CLARIFICATION ON THIS.
THIS SYSTEM IS RUNNING AT A 60%
LOS. TO THESE AREAS TO THE EAST
SIDE OF THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
I'VE SPOKE IN NUMEROUS TIMES MY
FIRST FEW YEARS UP HERE --
COLLEAGUES YOU WILL HELP ME DEAL
WITH YOU SIDE PORT OF FILL.
IN THE HUGE CRISIS WE HAD THERE
WITH IT BEING THE CITY WITHOUT
WATER.
THAT WAS DUE TO THE SUBSIDENCE.
THIS CAN NOW FEEDS THAT CITY.
THAT'S THE LARGEST ANNEXATION
PROJECT IN STATE HISTORY.
AND THE FRIED KERN CANAL PLAYS A
VITAL ROLE.
IN THOSE PEOPLE HAVING CLEAN
DRINKING WATER.
NOT TO MENTION ALL OF THE OTHER
[inaudible]
NUMEROUS [inaudible]
TOWNS.
COMMUNITIES COUNTY ISLANDS.
THAT ARE EXTREMELY DISADVANTAGED.
THAT ARE SIMPLY TOO FAR OUT TO
REACH TO TIE IN TO BE ANNEXED.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING I DEAL
WITH DAILY AND MY DISTRICT SO
COLLEAGUES ANY OF YOU THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN ACTUALLY SEEN THIS
FOR HAD STE AND I WELCOME YOU TO
COME DOWN I WILL CARVE OUT ANY
TIME IN MY SCHEDULE TO BE THERE
FOR YOU.
IN TO DRIVE YOU OUT TO THESE
AREAS AND AND WALK YOU THROUGH
IT -- BUT THINK ABOUT THAT.
THINK ABOUT HOW YOU WOULD FEEL.
IF YOU'RE WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
WAS AT A 60%.
LOS.
YOU WOULD BE DOING THE SAME
THING YOU WOULD BE ASKING ALL OF
US AS YOUR COLLEAGUES.
AND EVERYBODY FROM ACROSS THE
STATE QUITE FRANKLY ACROSS THE
COUNTRY LIKE WE ARE.
BY REACHING OUT WITH SENATOR
FEINSTEIN'S OFFICE AND THE
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION. TO GET
HELP.
THAT IS SIMPLY WHAT WE ARE DOING
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF FAMILIES AT STAKE.
AND TO SIMPLY LOOK AT THIS AND
SAY WELL ADDS GOING TO BENEFIT
AG.
TO IS IT REALLY FAIR TO THOSE
FAMILIES.
BECAUSE IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY THE NUMBER ONE INDUSTRIES
AGRICULTURE SO IT'S THAT SECTOR
IF IT'S NOT THERE TO DUST BOWL
IN MY EYES WILL COLLECT MY
ANCESTORS THE OKIE'S AND JUST
PACK UP AND LEAVE [inaudible]
BUT THIS IS FOR THEIR FAMILIES
THIS SO THEIR KIDS.
CAN ACTUALLY GET UP AND BRUSH
THEIR TEETH SO THE A FLUSH THEIR
TOILETS SO THEY CAN ACTUALLY
HAVE.
VIABLE WATER TO COOK WITH.
AND I'VE SEEN IT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS
BEING IN THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY
GOAL WITHOUT CLEAN POSSIBLE
WATER.
THIS IS A HUGE STEP WE CAN ALL
TAKE TOGETHER. TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT SO I UNDERSTAND IF IT
THIS.
IS SEEN AS A DISTRICT PROJECT OR
NOT SEEN AS TAKING CARE OF YOUR
AREA.
THE YOUR AREA IS GOING TO HAVE
NEEDS IN THE FUTURE AND YOU'RE
GONNA NEED ALL THE VALLEY CAUCUS
MEMBERS TO COME IN AND HELP YOU
AND WE WILL.
BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT PUTTING
PEOPLE FIRST NOT POLITICS
MEMBERS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THE BIGGEST SUMMER GARCIA.
AT THANK YOU CHAIR -- I WANT TO
BE SENSITIVE TO THE FACT THAT WE
DO HAVE COMMUNITIES -- THAT
SHOULDN'T BE LEFT BEHIND ALL
OVER THE STATE -- YOU HEAR FROM
ME EVERY YEAR IS TO TALK ABOUT
THESE COMMUNITIES IN MY BACKYARD.
AND I HOPE MR MAT THIS TO GET
SOMEBODY WITH SOME OF THOSE
BILLS THAT ARE COMING THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE AGAIN THIS YEAR.
AND I OFTEN GET ASKED A QUESTION
A WHY OTHER PEOPLE WHO DID AND
COST A PROBLEM RATHER PEOPLE
SHOULD BENEFIT.
I YOU KNOW SHOULD HAVE TO PAY
FOR SOMETHING THAT THEY DIDN'T
DO.
AND AFTER SAY I'VE I'VE LOOKED
AT ALL THE OTHER CHOICES AND AND
I NEED TO FIND A WAY TO TAKE THE
SOAPBOX AND A HALF HERE LEVERAGE
WHATEVER I CAN TO MAKE SURE I
SOLVE IT FOR THESE PEOPLE.
ALI TALK ABOUT WATER I HAVE
COMMUNITIES IN MY OWN BACKYARD
THAT ARE STRUGGLING TO IS LIKE
THIS -- WATER DISTRICT TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO PAY FOR REPAIRS TO
THAT WE ARE NOT LOSING 60% BUT
WHATEVER WE'RE LOSING.
OUT THEIR OWN AND THAT WE DON'T
RUN INTO THIS CONSERVE INTO WE
DON'T HAVE A SYSTEM THAT WORKS
ANYMORE.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN QUALIFIED FOR
FOR BONDS -- THEY HAVING
QUALIFIED FOR LOANS THEY HAVE
RAISE RATES TO THE POINT WHERE
THE COMMUNITIES KIND OF AT THE
BREAKING POINT AND WE CAN'T
AFFORD ANYMORE -- AND THEY'VE
ONLY BEEN ABLE TO FIND ABOUT ONE
THIRD OF OF THE OF THE REPAIRS
THAT THEY NEED AND THAT AND THEN
FOR STRUCTURE -- AND I THINK
IT'S THE BIGGER DISCUSSION OF
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE WE THE
SYSTEM WE HAVE HIS WORKING FOR
SOMEONE OFF EVERYONE AND WE HEAR
ABOUT THIS EVERY YEAR WHETHER
IT'S OUR BONDS ON WATER -- AND
SO FORTH.
I I HAVE -- EAT AND AND SO IT'S
WHEN PEOPLE CAME TO TALK ABOUT
CYCLE I HAVE PROBLEMS THAT ARE
RELATED TO THIS WE CAN'T FIND
THE MONEY EITHER HOW DO I MAKE
SURE OF BECAUSE EVENT OF WATER
DISTRICT -- HAS THE MONEY THEY
NEED WHEN THEY'RE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN AND DOING
THEIR PEACE -- BUT IT DOES I I
DO HAVE CONCERNS WITH WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT A FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT'S BEEN SO
ADVERSARIAL. TO US RIGHT AND AND
WHETHER OR NOT WE ARE GIVING
THEM SOMETHING -- ALONG THE WAY
I'M GOING TO BE.
SUPPORTING THIS BILL IN THE
THINGS BIRTH THAT I ASK ALL OF
YOU GUYS IS A POOR AND MAKE SURE
WOULD ONLY BEHIND WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES THIS ADVANTAGE
COMMUNITIES.
ARE AND AND YOU WILL CONTINUE TO
HEAR FROM FROM THE ON THAT ISSUE
FOR THE NEXT FIVE YEARS THAT I'M
HERE.
BUT I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE THAT I TALK ABOUT THE
DISCOMFORT I HAVE -- BEEN COMING
IN TO DO SOMETHING THAT I REALLY
FEEL THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SHOULD BE DOING.
I AND I HOPE THAT YOU ARE
SUCCESSFUL IN YOUR ADVOCACY IN
THE AT IN DC.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT.
IF AG IS GOING TO BE BENEFITING
FROM THIS THAT THEY'RE PAYING
THEIR FAIR SHARE.
ALONG THE WAY AND WE'LL DISCUSS
THIS EVEN AS WE TALK ABOUT HOW
DO WE CLEAN UP OUR WATER RIGHT
THROUGH OUR CAP AND TRADE
DOLLARS AND HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
IT STAYS CLEAN.
AND AND THE RESPONSIBILITY WILL
HAVE INCLUDING THE ACT COMMUNITY.
ALONG THE WAY AND SO.
I'M GONNA KEEP EMPHASIZING THAT
I GUESS AN IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
ECONOMY I GET THAT BUT WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE ALL PAIN ARE FOR
SURE.
ALONG THE WAY FOR THE
SUSTAINABLE SYSTEM ON AND SO I
ECHO SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT
MY COLLEAGUE FROM GLENDALE --
BROUGHT UP ALONG THE WAY SO
ELOQUENTLY EARLIER -- BUT TO
THEIR I WILL SUPPORT THE EFFORTS
OF OF OUR SENATOR AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN THAT AREA AS THEY TRY
TO BRING REPEAT FOR THOSE.
FAMILIES THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COMMENTS.
SEE NO COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- SOME
SENATORS SOME MEMBER SELECT TO
CLOSE.
WELL JUST.
MENTION THAT RECENTLY LEHMAN
DON'T GO WITH THE GOVERNOR'S.
GO BATES OFFICE WASN'T FRESNO
TALKING ABOUT HOW REGION'S NEED
TO RISE TOGETHER. FOR REGION'S
TO RISE TOGETHER OF OUR GROUND A
SINKING BENEATH US.
AND WE'RE REALLY LOOKING TOWARDS
THIS COMMITTEE TO HELP US COME
UP WITH SOME SOLUTIONS.
TOWARDS RECHARGE AND LEADING
TOWARD SUSTAINABILITY THAT CAN
ONLY BE DONE BY THE REPAIRS THAT
WERE RECOMMENDING IN THE FRONT
KERN CANAL.
WITH THAT TIE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TONIGHT POTENT JUST I'M
SO PLEASED TO BE HERE WITH HER
SENATOR ASKING. FOR A REGION'S
BEHALF CENTER LET'S CLOSE.
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK PER NIGHT
BUT YOU HAVE A MOTION.
SOME MEMBER BIGELOW SECOND BY
MISTER MATHIS.
AND YOU ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
AB PLEASE WELCOME.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA HI
GARCIA I GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW Y. CHOI.
CHOI I CHIU.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NOT VOTING [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA.
XENA GARCIA I GLORIA.
KALRA [inaudible]
LEVINE.
MATHIS I MATHIS AYE BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO ICE SALAS.
SALAS SIDE WOULD.
WOULD I SIXTY FORTY THAT OPEN
FOR THE MEMBERS CHAD ON THIS
TIME THANK YOU PRESS ENTER SOME
NUMBER WILL.
GO TO THE TOP OF THE AGENDA AND
ADD OTHER MEMBERS -- THE FIRST
[inaudible]
YEAH. NINETY THREE SB SIXTY NINE
THAT WILL -- GO TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
SB.
TWO TWO SIX FRIEDMAN.
ONCE.
START WHICH BOTH SB.
TWO TWO SIX NIELSEN.
FRIEDMAN I AREA [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
SALAS.
SB.
TWO TWO SIX SALAS I WOULD.
I WOULD I TWENTY TWO ZERO AS THE
TOP TWO ZERO THAT BILL GETS OUT.
SB [inaudible]
THREE NINETY FIVE GLORIA
[inaudible]
LEVINE.
WOULD.
WOULD I SEVEN TWO ZERO SEVEN TWO
ZERO BILLBOARDS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
NO NOT YET.
I IT WE NEED ONE MORE.
SB FOUR ZERO TWO GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
LEVINE.
WOULD.
WOULD I NINE TWO ZERO NINE ZERO
BILL MEANT ITSELF.
SB [inaudible]
FOUR FOUR TWO GALLAGHER.
WOULD.
WOULD I THIRTEEN TO ZERO
THIRTEEN TO ZERO THE BILL GETS
OUT.
THE ASIANS.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SB FORTY
SEVEN AND SB SEVEN SEVEN NINE
GALLAGHER.
WOULD.
WOULD I THIRTEEN TO ZERO
THIRTEEN TWO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AND WILL -- LEAVE IT OPEN. FOR
FIVE MINUTES FOR OTHER MEMBERS
TO ADD ON I MEMBERS.
SB [inaudible]
FIVE FIVE NINE GLORIA
[inaudible]
YEAH. TO START AT THE TOP
OKAY [inaudible]
ALRIGHT -- OKAY AS THREE TWO TWO
SIX GLORIA [inaudible]
HI.
GLORIA I THIRTEEN ZERO THE KIDS
OUT.
SB THREE NINETY FIVE GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA. FIVE GALLAGHER I
GLORIA.
GLORIA NOT VOTING.
IT'S EIGHT ZERO SECOND SOUND.
SB FOUR ZERO TWO GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
LARGEST -- I GALLAGHER I THAT'S
TEN TWO ZERO SB FOR FOURTEEN
GALLAGHER. FOUR FOUR TWO HI
GALLAGHER I FOURTEENTH
[inaudible]
TWO ZERO GET SOUND.
CONSENT CALENDAR GALLAGHER -- HI
GALLAGHER I FOURTEEN TWO ZERO SB
FIVE FIVE NINE GALLAGHER.
I GALLAGHER I GLORIA.
GLORIA I THANKS [inaudible]
NINE TEN TWO ZERO SECOND HOUR.
I THINK I WILL STILL WAITING.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO ADJOURN THIS
MEETING THANK YOU VERY MUCH